I'd like to welcome everybody to today's
hearings at the Ed with the education
committee here uh before we get into the
first hearing which is 1185 there's a
sheet coming around uh which is an
updated report on the revenues that
we're receiving in our trust fund and
all um that uh will be important to look
at in terms of we have four bills to
been the subcommittee dealing with
fiscal matters we met in Friday this is
for your you to have right now we will
discuss it later but don't don't don't
lose this uh spreadsheet uh shows the
revenues and Appropriations within it um
going on to the first bill I'd like to
invite the prime sponsor of the bill
representative Reed uh this is relative
to sexual education instruction I only
yeah thank you Mr chairman members of
the education committee my name is Karen
Reid I represent um Hillsboro District
27 daring and francistown I'm here to um
introduce House Bill
1185 which is the um human um sex
education um bill I want to preface my
testimony by telling you that um I've
been a registered nurse since
1991 um a majority of my practice was as
a school nurse um and my largest school
was 500 students um ages prek through
fifth
grade and I would like to also say
that sex is an adult activity with adult
consequences during the periods between
preschool and High School is a time of
tremendous growth both physical
emotional and mental and academic growth
learning does not stop once a student
graduates as Educators you are aware
that we are trying to um produce
lifelong Learners sex ed should continue
at an age appropriate level after high
school so my point being we shouldn't
have to feel like we need to cram
everything in before they graduate
there's plenty of time to learn when
graduate there is currently a trend
toward the adoption of planned
parenthood's comprehensive sex ed also
known as csse curriculum in K12
classrooms throughout the country I
would like to provide my rationale for
why New Hampshire should not follow suit
Planned Parenthood has been deeply
involved in setting the national sex
sexuality education standards or NES
from which they benefit via millions of
dollars in Grants from the US Department
of Health and Human Services to provide
curriculum a significant conflict of
interest they are using these standards
in related curriculum to promote a
radical gender ideology that denies
science and creates dangerous conflicts
between parents and their children and
between the child and their own psyche
the csse endorses moral relativism of
controversial sexual behaviors and
relationships that are in conflict with
most American cultural norms religious
beliefs and family values Planned
Parenthood is a sec is the second
largest supplier of cross- sex hormones
in this country so it is obvious their
interest in controlling the sexual
education of our young people is purely
economic and not for social good in
addition Planned Parenthood is one of
the largest providers of abortions in
this country and benefit financially
from unintended
pregnancies a com a common criticism of
Planned Parenthood developed NES
standard is that they expose children to
age impro in age inappropriate sexual
material and this is where I personally
have an issue robbing them of their
innocence and increasing the potential
for Contracting sexually transmitted
diseases or experiencing psychological
damage for example csse teaches gender
ID identity to kindergarteners and trans
to kindergarteners and trans
gender transgender puberty blockers to
third graders a related teacher resource
suggests sterilization as a form of
birth control to 11 to 13y olds it also
suggests withholding information about a
gender's identity confusion from parents
and the main curriculum strives to
encourage children to seek counsel from
trusted adults rather than their parents
while paying lip service to parents'
roles in nurturing their children's know
of
sexuality in addition csse includes irre
irrelevant content to promote their
gender ideology agenda and fails to
focus the curriculum on topic at hand
the life behaviors of a sexually healthy
adult include statement like interact
with all genders instead of both in
respectful and appropriate ways affirm
one's own gender identities and respect
the gender identities of others so if a
child were to affirm that there are only
male and female genders as a as science
holds true the child would be considered
unhealthy according to these guidelines
for example the subconcepts are rif with
statements such as reject stereotyp
stereotypes about the sexuality of
different populations avoid behaviors
that exhibit Prejudice and bigotry
critically examine cultural critically
examine um critically examine the world
around them for bias based on gender
sexual orientation culture ethnic
ethnicity and race what does that have
to do with sex ed for the purpose of
avoiding STDs and unintended pregnancies
the Planned Parenthood curriculum is
more IDE ideology and indoctrination
than sex education key concept num
number six society and culture topic
five is diversity developmental messages
about diversity for level four this is
from the Planned Parenthood curriculum
include confronting one's own bias and
Prejudice can be difficult and
workplaces benefit from having employees
for from diverse backgrounds again what
does this have to do with sexual
education this represents the in
infiltration of irrelevant Dei pedology
into supposed to be sex education under
a section purportedly designed to
promote adult sexual health entitled
goals in information they noticeably
admit abstinence while including
abortion contraception master ation G
gender ideality idea gender identity
sexual orientation and other
controversial topics a frequently cited
reason for parents' decision to
homeschool their CH children is their
objection to Cs and lgbtq education
content in public schools in the value
section the SE C States young people
should view themselves as unique and
worthwhile individuals within the
context of their cultural herit AG so
are they promoting other n Nations
cultural views views on the treatment of
women and homosexuals as something
American children should accept will
this lead to the Future increase in
honor killings femicide and hate crimes
why caveat this value with context
another value stated is the pl in a
pluralistic society people should
respect and accept the diversity of
values and beliefs about sex sexuality
that exists in a community the United
States motto is urbus nunum Unum out of
many one we are a Melting Pot people
come to America from many cultures but
are expected and need to assimilate to
our culture which is based on
judeo-christian values enshrined in our
founding documents we need our children
to be educated to a value system that is
compatible and consistent with these
American values the concern here is that
large populations of migrants and even
legal immigrants who have not
assimilated to the American values is
leading to an increase in femicide and
violence against homosexuals in our
country quite a bit of curriculum is
spent on sexual orientation and dend
gender identity ideology rather than on
material relevant to heterosexuals which
make up the vast majority of the
population in this state the material
also has misleading statements such as
two people who live together without
being married can have the same
commitment and responsibility toward one
another as married people this is not
true as marriage involves certain legal
commitments rights and benefits that are
not conferred on common law cohabitants
the material appears to have a bias
against traditional marriage and
heterosexual relationships spending an
inordinate amount of time on
non-traditional relationships and sexual
orientations more time is spent on
divorce than on many advantages of legal
heterosexual marriages if if we want a
happier more financially secure and
properly functioning Society we should
be Pro promoting The Proven benefits of
legal marriage over living arrangements
to quote a study by W will Cox at Al
2005 experts on marriage and family
recently summarized the benefits of
healthy marriages for women men and
children and found better relationships
between parents and children as well as
numerous economic physical health and
mental health advantages for both adults
and children single Parenthood is the
single biggest contribut contributor to
Pro poverty and crime a majority of New
Hampshire parents want schools to
provide sex comprehensive sex education
including information about abstinence
sexually transmitted diseases HIV AIDS
contraception and disease prevention
method methods New Hampshire sexual
education should focus on transmitting
fact-based
scientific and medical information about
human sexuality and related conditions
and diseases and avoid sidebar
discussions around sexual values or
legislation dealing with sexual issues
after all these children are not even a
voting age and indoctrination isn't is
inappropriate in an already too short
school
day um this this B what prompted me to
um propo us to propose this legislation
is I had been following the
comprehensive sex education as it
migrated from California to to
Connecticut in the east coast our
executive committee um stopped funding
for this um this type of sex ed because
they found problems with the curriculum
they found that um it did in fact speak
out both sides of its mouth it told
parents you know it presented you know
the opportunity to be to have parents
involved in the process and being
transparent yet once the students were
in the classroom
they told the kids like Las Vegas what
stays in this CL what happens in this
classroom stays in this classroom now
all those children bring different
things to the table um by not being able
to discuss what they're learning with
their parents Guardians grandparents
whoever that's going to cause a conflict
with students we in the United States
are Melting Pot of so many beautiful
wonderful cultures that each have their
own views around what they want their
kids to know about family life if we are
pushing these these these tenants on
kids who you know who don't whose
families and cultures don't espouse this
we're causing unnecessary conflict so um
the executive committee halted the
funding and said no you know this is not
appropriate for our schools however
Senator Hassan uh Maggie Hassen went and
secured funding through am muskog health
to get um the New Hampshire version of
this is prep personal responsibility
education um program and so I I called
the am muskog Health to see you know if
if they can you know give me any
direction and and I was told it's not in
every District um and it's just in
certain school districts Manchester
being one of them so I reached out to
Manchester and to see you know to see
what what you know how they determined
which schools and which student
populations would would have access to
this and crickets you know no no nothing
back um so uh also you know of course um
the the the uh curriculums are
copyrighted so I could not provide you
with outlines or guide which what was my
hope I wanted to be able to at least you
know pass it around and I couldn't do to
copyright there are alternate um
wonderful um programs that schools each
individual District can and buy a
purchase um that you know that follow
our guidelines and are more less um go
down to two minutes you know uh intense
is for our thank you very much we we've
gone around for 15 minutes now are there
any questions for the representative
from the
committee not yes representa Ryan thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question um I have here a an
amendment yes and I was wondering what
the difference was between them okay so
yes in the amendment we did change the
wording um from uh sexual education
instruction to Sexual Health we also
made some minor uh word changes and um
remove the um penalties for not that was
my criminal justice hat uh removing the
penalties for um any um you know uh
deviating from the standards and this
does still allow for local
control
um yeah so basically it's just some word
changes um and all of this is it seems
wordy but it's a lot of definitions
actually thank you very much further
questions from the committee thank you
thank you i' like to invite
representative
Tanner we are now going to due to the
time availability we're going to go down
to what we normally do we take 2 minutes
per person and their presentations
following the prime
sponsor thank you Mr chair um I'm Linda
Tanner representative for sunpan
Springfield Sullivan District 5 um I was
have a Bachelor of Science and health
education um and I taught sex education
for probably 30 out of my 35 years um
our it was a two- we section um that
occurred in our health education grade
nine and when it was started uh and
throughout we had Parents um on come in
and uh discuss what was going on in the
sex education uh part of the health
education and offer suggestions and and
whatever they the comments they wanted
to make um because before for a number
of years te uh parents weren't really
allowed to exempt their kids from sex
education now um today if a parent first
of all the information that is provided
is given out 14 days before the health
education class uh reviews that and then
parents are allowed to actually um
withdraw from that section of the course
and provide their own
information um to so that some
information is getting to the student so
if somebody objects to this
they're they have every opportunity to
withdraw from it if it's not part of
their value
system they can withdraw from this part
of the the um course so uh first of all
I want to point out that this bill is
unnecessary because of those guidelines
secondly I want to I can't I'm getting
nervous because I I just can't deal with
teachers indoctrination teachers don't
indoctrinate okay they offer skills they
offer learning they offer content
area my job teachers jobs are not to
browbeat kids to a certain system so
it's it's also a dangerous bill
because if kids don't get accurate sex
education if they don't learn things
from people like School nurses people
who have a degree in health
education they are learning from their
peers they are learning from those
pornographic magazines they can get
either at the store or online they are
learning from adults who want to do
different things to them that may not be
uh appropriate and may be very dangerous
so it's dangerous not to have sex
education and as our previous speaker
said representative can you please wrap
it up you've gone by your two minutes
that the majority of parents and
students the youth advisory committee
actually two years ago had a panel
discussion on why we weren't doing more
sex education uh want sex education want
the diversity in school want social
emotional learning and I've passed out a
sheet um that tells you uh what should
what I think should happen and what does
happen in schools and also a little note
at the top that uh people are passing
through puberty earlier and earlier now
it's 8 to13 for girls and a girl
ovulates before we've got that sheet in
front of us so we're going to have toang
quits here okay G are there any
questions of Representative Tanner yes
represent Miler thank you Mr chair and
thank you for being here you had
indicated in your testimony
that uh parents are involved in the
program and in fact they can exempt
their child if they want to how many
parents in your 30 years of history of
teaching this course have Exempted their
child from being involved in this
program probably less than 10 thank you
represent beler thank you Mr chair and
thank you for your testimony um you
indicated that indoctrination doesn't
happen in schools it's not something
teachers are doing uh as it relates to
this bill but the the simple definition
of an indoctrinate is simply to instruct
in a body of Doctrine or principles is
that not what we're discussing here is
not isn't everything to do with how
sexual legation is taught and what it is
a matter of Doctrine and principles this
this um whole push about
indoctrination is and I wish I could use
the term but it is totally misinformed
and misdirected you can take any
definition you want but teachers are our
whole profession is set up to to not
allow like not allow students or not to
inform students as to what our religion
is what our political ideology is what
our values are as far as
sex education is concerned that's not
the job the job is to inform kids to
give them the skills to give them
critical thinking so that and
decision-making skills so that they can
make their own decisions this happens to
be one of the areas that's very
important that parents are involved in
and that I know the previous speaker
said that you know in one class they
heard you know it's like Las Vegas
whatever is said in this class only
stays in this class that doesn't pertain
to the um education that's happening in
that class that pertains to the
questions other students ask um so that
a student doesn't go home and say you
know representative Miler ask a question
about blah blah blah um but in my class
and I think I would say that 90% of the
people that teach it have different
parts in the class where you're supposed
to go home and talk to your parents it's
it's it's so that the parents get to
give their read on the situation and and
what and the values they want to
instill further questions represent P
now thank you and thank you for taking
my question I believe I heard you say
that students
need to have sex education and I'm
confused because I don't think this Bill
is saying that students shouldn't have
it it's just giving a different an
alternative to what you're suggesting
the students need is that well let me
let me point out to you particularly on
page three okay sections 6 7 8 and N um
tie the hand of a person who's trying to
a trained professional way information
and skill building activities evidence
formed inclusive
lgbtq plus youth trauma informed and
adap Ed to the needs of the community
totally totally binds the hands of of a
teacher that's trying to effectively
teach sex
education represent cascaden did you
have your hand up um I did um just doing
a little bit of research it appears that
across the country there are four states
that have the best um curriculum for sex
education right now New Hampshire is one
of those four but also I want to know if
um I know the curriculum does not
require
consent I knew that the curriculum did
not require including instruction and
sexual orientation or gender identity
but is the curriculum being used still
the health curriculum that was
developed um and is listed on the
department of Ed is that still going on
in schools is that what they're using
so the the fact about across the state
of New Hampshire unless it's drastically
changed was that health education
although it was required by the
standards it is was often taught by the
physical education coach or you know to
take the girls one day and the boys the
other day and give them the film and a
little talk and answer some questions
right and um even when the legislative
youth uh group did a panel and did some
investigation and what sex education was
being taught across the state of New
Hampshire it was still just just really
a hodgepodge I think
the the schools that adopt set
curriculum like that often are are
schools that have people who aren't
professional uh in that particular um
subject and so they they try to do it
that way further questions from the
committee yes representative pel thank
you um representative Tanner can you
explain to me what the specific purpose
of sex
is
well um I'm not sure that um I'm an
expert in that but definitely uh sex has
to do with
reproduction and sex has to also do with
um I don't know where to go from there
that's kind of a stumper question thank
you very
much yes
cautiously go
ahead
thank you further further questions
thank you very much i' like to invite
representative
sidel the the card says 15 minutes but
we're to down to the
you well thank you Mr
chairman um part of the reason
a big part of the reason for this bill
when I was
campaigning with most people that I
spoke to I would say about 80% of the
people that I spoke to door too I asked
them what was your biggest issue and
about 80% of the time it was schools
school safety we had recently had in the
news a shooting that had happened I'm
sorry I didn't introduce myself uh
representative Sidell Sheila Sidell from
Hillsboro 2019 um and co-sponsored to
the bill um the biggest concern was the
schools as far far as safety as well as
what children are being taught that
they're not learning they're not their
proficiency is way down and what they're
also being taught that parents do not
want um discuss they want to to have for
themselves and that would having to do
with sexual education um this bill in no
way is to deny that there are trans
youth that there are lgbtqq youth it is
to put this back in the hands of the
parents they need the children need to
have biology
physiology explained to them and and how
that all comes to to play they don't
need their sexual Lifestyles told to
them given all the different options
that are out there for sexual Lifestyles
there's 107 of um gender identities
there's eight different sexual
orientations that in itself takes four
years of gender studies in college to
get an an adult student to understand
what the complexities are of this topic
and we're putting it in the minds of
young children that don't have the
mental capacity if it takes four years
for an adult student to understand it
how are we going to have a child that is
way younger than that understand it
um the other side of it is we
have 67 to 95% depending on the study
you look at 67 to 95% of these students
that
um are hearing this information by the
time they're 18 they have accepted their
birth gender they're they're no longer
confused because they are now getting to
the maturity where they they're getting
more comfortable with who they
are um so that is I it really is it it's
been brought forward by the parents that
I've spoken to by the grandparents I've
spoken to and the teachers that I've
spoken to that are that are trying to
figure out where can they where they
walk on this this very narrow path
that's been created thank you very much
are there any questions of the
representative yes representa
cordelli uh thank you um I just wanted
to uh touch on I think it's both in the
original bill and the amendment um
Romans 6 uh uh talks about what shall
not be included in um instruction or
provision of
materials
um which includes gender uh expression
um orientation and Lifestyles as you as
you mentioned but also um included is um
in Roman 9 UM the uh anti-discrimination
statutes which um prevent discrimination
on any one of those topics um can you
tell me how that um six and nine apply
to each
other well in six it's telling us what
we can what we can or cannot expose the
children to
discrimination means not singling out
one not and that's the opposite of of
inclusivity um we are to teach them in a
more broad subject not isolating into
one particular area and and certainly
not um exposing them to materials that
they're mentally not capable of of
processing thank you thank you further
questions from the committee
representative cascaden thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question I
guess I ask why wouldn't you just repeal
186 colon 11a it'll be one less thing
for the schools to to have why would you
go repe why wouldn't you repeal instead
of submitting a
Bill thank you for your question I don't
have an answer for you I'm sorry
representative uh Cornell thank you and
thank you for taking my question um
Section 8 says says human sexual
education will be taught by a registered
nurse and no human sexual education
instructed teacher shall do it um there
are many schools that don't have a nurse
at all um in New Hampshire and they're
pretty busy so if they don't if a school
doesn't have a nurse and they don't have
time to do it this doesn't happen
correct uh no we can well the way it's
written yes I I see what you're saying
yes thank you further questions thank
you very much thank you I'd like to
Trumble good morning Mr chairman
committee members my name is David
Trumble from the town of where I'm
opposed to this bill
first of all comprehensive sex education
does more than prevent teen pregnancies
it also reduces Dating Violence and it
reduces children's sex abuse by teaching
children at an early stage about not
being touched inappropriately studies
show a 30-year study that comprehensive
sex head reduces child sex abuse and it
reduces Dating Violence that's from the
American Academy Pediatrics and also the
Journal of adolescent
Health another problem with this bill is
that it basically writes lgbtq issues
out of sex education they're not
included in the areas that are mandated
to be instructed and they are
specifically included in the areas that
are precluded from being instructed
having a program that teaches about
lgbtq issues leads to a safe and
welcoming school and it reduces bullying
that three decade study at actually was
a review of 80s studies showed that when
you have a good LGBT Q courses as part
of your comprehensive sex ed you reduce
bullying and you increase awareness of
discrimination and oppression it also
goes on to talk about um how uh
decreased is the name calling in
willingness to intervene when witnessing
name calling by others and an increase
in a belief that children and people
have the right to be who they are and
I'll submit written testimony so you can
review that for yourself but the point
is basically that this sort of a bill
would result in ignorance because
children will not be getting taught at
all about
lgbtq and they need that sex education
is effective when it's properly
presented and that should be an
important part of what's done the last
objection to this bill is the section
seven that says it's reserved solely for
that class what happens in other
classrooms like for instance when a
teacher has lgbtq books on their
bookshelf must they now be removed and
if that teacher doesn't would they lose
their teaching license this bill is so
vague that I think it basically would
intimidate teachers from even addressing
the question any kind of a teacher
whether it's an English teacher or or a
nurse or a phys that teacher or a
science teacher uh with only two minutes
I'll stop there thank you Mr chairman
thank you very much if you've written
testimony we'd appreciate that being
submitted to the yes sir represent
cordelli uh thank you um thank you for
your testimony this morning um could you
tell me where in statute it says that
lgbtq issues are to be taught in sexual
education
where where in statute it's the the bill
or in current Statute in current statute
I I don't I I'm not saying that it is
mandated in current statute but it's not
prohibited in current statute and I
believe it is a part of what's called
comprehensive sex education the prime
sponsor of the bill was speaking against
that and what I'm I was citing to you a
study of comprehensive sex said that
says including lgbtq issues reduces
bullying and uh M discrimination could
you provide us a copy of that study
possi I I have in the evidence of
testimony I'll give you there's a direct
link it's okay thank you it's it's
called three decades of research the
case for comprehensive sex education
it's in the Journal of adolescent Health
October of 2020 thank you thank you very
much further questions yes
representative Damon thank you Mr chair
good morning and thank you for being
here would you agree or would you
comment on this is actually followup to
representative cordell's question to the
previous speaker um Romans 6 and Roman
9 isn't it a conflict to prohibit in
Romans
6 any instruction or provision of
materials regarding I won't read the
whole thing but gender identity gender
expression Etc and then to say to quote
RSA 354 in Roman 9 this act prohibits
discrimination against age sex gender
identity sexual orientation if you
ignore gender identity aren't you
discriminating against it I would agree
with your thank you representative Damon
I would agree with your interpretation I
think the authors of this are trying to
say in section six we're writing lgbtq
out there will be no discussion of it in
sexed or anywhere else in the school
they don't exist from an educational
standpoint but we're not going to allow
anybody to say anything directly that
would discriminate against somebody so
we're going to write you out of
existence but if somebody says something
against you then you would be up against
a discrimination law thank you thank you
represent
Bel thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony uh you testified that uh
in this bill the lgbtq issues are are
written out of the sexuality education
which is currently a part of
comprehensive sex sexuality education um
so in in current and when I was there
sexuality education consisted of
learning about things like penile
vaginal intercourse how it can result in
a child and how diseases can be
transmitted in that way can you with
some degree of specificity identify what
lgbtq issues are or should be taught in
this class thank you representative
beler so the study that I cited on
comprehensive sex education said that
it's generally agreed that that sex
education reduces sexually transmitted
diseases and reduces teenage pregnancy
this study looked at what are the other
things that can be included in
comprehensive sex education and are they
beneficial and they looked at it and
said it reduces Dating Violence it
reduces child sex abuse and it reduces
bullying so there are more things than
just focusing on sexually transmitted
diseases and teen pregnancy those are
certainly core components but the the
point is is that comprehensive sex ed
would would go beyond
that if I may just have a brief followup
uh thank you for uh the the information
on the studies but but that none of that
t said exactly what is actually being
taught under the lgbtq rubric or what
taught there's a lot there but I would
say basically the concepts of acceptance
of all people for who they are is is one
um I I I I will submit my written
testimony it I submitted about seven or
eight quotes from the study which goes
into a little more detail but the point
I'm just trying to make is there's more
to comprehensive sex ed than just
sexually transmitted diseases and teen
pregnancy and a a comprehensive approach
would provide other benefits if we agree
that General sex head is effective in
reducing teen pregnancy then we know
that having an instructor talk to
Children is a good thing to happen and
all I'm saying is that there are other
things Beyond simply those two things
that can also be beneficial from a
public health standpoint thank you are
there any more questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
banet thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee Jil B I'm the legal
director at theu of New Hampshire we
oppose this bill uh I know I only have
two minutes um so I'll try to to keep it
uh brief um I have not seen the
amendment by the way I've only seen the
original the original version um uh I
just kind of one one kind of opening
headline is to the extent that this bill
is trying to kind of get at um obscenity
uh which seems like might be one of the
intentions at least based on the
definitions though I didn't hear
much of that during the sponsors
testimony I just did want to flag for
folks that we already have a harmful to
minor statute I know that's come up with
respect to other bills but I just wanted
to amplify and uplift that here for the
committee harmful to minor statutes
applies to to everyone individual
schools Etc so I do think in many
respects we already have Protections in
place with respect to um things that are
meet the standard for uh obscenity and I
also do want to flag out flag um that
school districts as required by a 2017
law um already have objectional
materials policies under RSA 186 colon
um 11 Roman numeral 9-c which require 14
days of notice for curriculum course
material used for instruction of human
sexuality or human sexual uh education
so we already have through this 2017 law
basically an opt out right when notice
is provided to to parents and they can
opt out um you know when they're given
notice within 14 days so I just wanted
to flag that and maybe that addresses
many of the concerns that have already
been raised I'm not sure but I do think
we already have um that that uh that
protection um in in place now what this
bill does is it goes a little bit
further right and it's essentially an
opin law under its Provisions but I just
wanted to flag that we already have some
existing laws on this um I just do want
to highlight two Provisions that I think
are particular a particular concern um
to us and there's one section of the
bill that states that human section ual
education shall be reserved solely for
specific human sexual education classes
it shall not be taught or included at
any way in any other academic subject
instruction or curriculum and I think I
would just identify that that is on uh
page three M numeral 7 and I and I think
there's some concerns with that right
human sexual education is not really
specifically defined at least from what
I can tell um in the bill uh and so I
think this this could really implicate
very broad things right um including the
definition of self- resect respect of
all other peoples which is one of the
definitions or one of the criteria or
components of of sexual education in the
bill so I think this restriction is
really impractical because material in
nonsexual education classes often
implicates right sexuality right you can
think about like reading Romeo and
Juliet right the content of that of
course gone by your two minutes okay
well I think that I just want to
highlight that I think that is very
impractical right because there are
other courses that obviously implicate
sexuality and I think this says that
that they can't do that and I think
that's just doesn't make a lot of sense
the last thing I just do want to say I
know and I I'm sorry that I'm going over
is the targeting of lgbtq folks here I
think is is a real thing and it is a
concern that we have in section six um
of the bill um and and really I think
it's it stigmatizes the community of
course one cannot engage in sexual
education instruction without
discussions I think of sexual
orientation sexual preferences these
things of course are going to come up in
conversations so excluding them I think
is both impractical and and um really
doesn't meet the needs of of many of
those students so um with that I'll
conclude my testimony and I want to
thank the committee's time and for those
reasons we represent
belshire thank you Mr chair and thank
you for your testimony I just wanted to
clarify one piece because you said that
there is uh already Protections in our
schools for children from being shown
obscene materials um in law but are you
aware that that law in New in New
Hampshire specifically exempts all
schools from uh from it being enforced
uh I'm not aware of that being the case
the now I think what you might be
referring to is the not the harmful to
minor statute I reference but the
criminal obscenity statute is that what
you're referring to representative
that's correct yes so um it is true that
that exempts uh schools it exempts K
through2 private schools as well right
um but I don't think that exemption
exist exists under the harmful to minor
statute which is why that is the statute
I referenced and not the criminal
obscenity statute thank you further
questions thank you very much thank you
manzelli thank you good morning chairman
lad members of the committee my name is
Amy manzelli I'm here to testify on
behalf of myself and my husband as
citizens of New Hampshire and residents
of Pembrook we are opposed to HB 185 as
amended I have not read the amendment
but I've heard an overview of its
intention and it does not fix the
problems with this
bill um I have some written testimony
but I'm going to skip over the um
personal story that I shared with you
about our transgender daughter Iris
who's 14 years old I'm going to go right
to um a different part of what we want
to share with you which is um how our
personal story fits into the context of
our shared American history and I want
to talk about three laws in
1967 the United States Supreme Court
ruled in loving be Virginia that
marriage is one of the basic civil
rights under our constitution the
freedom to marry a person of another
race resides with the individual
and the state cannot infringe on that
right and in that case MD and Richard
people of different races were able to
stay married and that was not a crime in
1971 the United States Supreme Court
ruled in re V read that to give a
mandatory
preference mandated solely on the basis
of sex is to make the very kind of
arbitrary legislative Choice our
constitution forbids so Sally Reed was
able to serve as the executrix of her
son's
estate and in
2015 the United States Supreme Court
ruled in oel V hajes that a person can
marry another person of whatever gender
they
want the court said
changed understandings are
characteristic of a
Nation where New Dimensions of free
generations just like our daughter
Iris none of the plaintiffs in these
cases were
dangerous none of them deserved to be
written out of the
story indeed what they
wanted was only to live their lives with
the freedoms Americans en jooy under our
nation's great
laws in the United States minutes thank
you I'm wrapping up and the United
States Supreme Court found the laws that
prevented them from doing so were on the
wrong side of American
History if passed this law would also be
on the wrong side of our American
history it wrongfully targets the lgbtq
plus minority for no
reason other than citizens in the lgbtq
plus Community they might be different
from some prior understandings passing
laws like this would be an unfounded
seizure of civil rights that our proud
American history should protect for all
Americans
equally please itl
1185 as amended are there any thank you
the committee yes representative Pell
thank you and thank you for taking my
question you mentioned marriage quite a
bit but I'm not sure where marriage is
mentioned in this bill and um I believe
your child transitioned at a very young
age and so my real question is how early
do you think sex education should have
start should start in
schools um in public schools it should
start in
preschool further questions from the
committee
thank you very much thank you all like
bfield in the interest of time I'm going
to make this very quick and I'm just
going to skip questions I hope you don't
mind but I know that we're now over um
first of all Amry Banfield I'm a
parental rights advocate in New
Hampshire focused on education I see
this bill as a transparency bill I think
that that's always
important I'll give you an example in
sixth grade I got a call from a
teacher and who was teaching my daughter
in sixth grade and said they're going to
be covering um reproduction in sixth
grade and to look at the science book
that she was using I went to it and it
was basic
biology something like that is so
important to parents and of course my
daughter learned the bi biological
information that was taught but her
reaching out to me and and this is what
I think people need to understand that
enforces that confirms that affirms my
daughter being in that school with that
teacher and I don't feel the need to
pull her out but when things are hidden
that's where it becomes a problem
another parent because I've been doing
this so long another parent um called me
years ago this has been years
ago she went to a presentation that the
school gave and everybody was there this
is what we're going over and then her
son came home fifth grade and burst into
tears because he thought he would be
wetting the
bed they thought he thought that from
the presentation and this is what the
wasn't explain to the parent at the at
the presentation but he was going to
start wetting the bed because of wet
dreams they weren't they didn't explain
it so he thought in fifth grade and had
he not come to his mother and told her
he would have had had that
information incorrect in his brain so
anytime we can be transparent I think
it's a
plus
um that's it I'm not going to go any
further I think everything else has been
said so thank you very much uh Jennifer
Smith yes she said she was not gonna
take
questions good morning chairman lad and
members of the committee thank you for
taking
testimony um I had signed in online
opposed to this and I kind of thought I
don't think I want to come um but and I
thought everybody else would say things
perfectly well without me but then I
thought about it some more and I thought
you know amending this bill into a study
committee would be a perfect opportunity
for people who have very different views
to talk to each other in detail which we
can't do this morning about why we
believe what we believe I think we all
want to protect our kids grandkids and
other people's kids and grandkids from
unnecessary infections
unnecessary pregnancies that may be even
intended or unintended but a bad idea
with poor
understanding and also and I will say
this to protect our lgbtq students
because there are different es in
sexuality that need to be explored for
them as well and how do you do this and
I do believe abstinence belongs in the
curriculum absolutely but also some
modifications of that because people are
people and sexuality is a very appealing
thing starting very early in puberty so
I I think you know to try to go into
questions of what's sexuality for what
specific things are important for queer
kids to have in the curriculum doesn't
make sense here today to me I'll try to
answer a question if I get asked it oh I
forgot to say I'm a retired medical
physician I also have a public health
degree infectious diseases including all
the venial diseases are an area of great
interest and always have been we are
currently in a problem with Rising rates
of that are very
worrisome and so you know we need to
think about does this help does this
hinder the overall situation not just
for your individual family or someone
else's individual family who it's been
noted can opt out do their own sex
education if they don't like this but we
need to think what makes sense for
people in general in most of our schools
our public
schools and I would submit that that
will not be something you can easily
tease out today or in your consideration
of this bill later and maybe turning
this into study committee would be an
opportunity for people to stop talking
past each other and talk to each other
thank you thank you very much doctor are
there questions from the committee thank
you very
bitman
good morning Nancy Beerman um I'm here
in support of 11 185 House Bill
1185 I'm here because um at this point
the trust between parents and schools
has deteriorated parents are questioning
their trust of what is being said in the
classroom they're being questioning what
is being taught and they don't trust
what teachers are saying and doing in
the
classroom this bill puts up the guard
rails and yes it does tie the teachers
hands as they should be there are rules
and there's areas that teachers should
not not step over the line and teachers
are stepping over that line more and
more every
day I was a teacher for 15 years and I
knew where the line was there were
topics that I did not discuss the
students may ask the question and I
would say you know that's a mommy and
daddy question and then I would let the
mom and dad know that your child had
this question at school today just
because the child ask the question does
not mean the teacher needs to answer
it as far as repealing
186 um
11a um I read this um part of the HSA
RSA sorry and um it directs the
department development academic
standards to serve as a guide and
reference in health physiology and
hygiene as they relate to the effects of
alcohol and other drugs and child abuse
in human HIV and AIDS and sexually tra
uh transmitted diseases or the humans on
the human system which are designed to
help help students lead longer and
healthier
lives all this does this bill does is
put in some more guidelines as to topics
that are not to be spoken and and
presented as truth because they're not
um and as far as the harmful to minor
statue of HB 57 um sorry RSA 571
B-2 I've been trying to apply this in my
school district and so far it's not
working so yes there are materials that
the school district says no we can still
keep and it doesn't matter if I think
they're harmful to miners thank you
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee thank you very much
Hartwell good morning and thank you for
allowing me to share my test
testimony I live in East Andover I'm a
native of New Hampshire and have
children who have been in the public
schools and grandchildren who are now in
the public schools I also have a
transon an adult and I have a
10-year-old grandchild
nonbinary I have read house Bill 1185
and studied it section n of the bill
claims to be in accordance to the RSA
354 the anti-discrimination law yet HB
1185 States in section six which has
already been mentioned the topic of
gender identity and gender expression
sexual orientation and Identity or any
other lifestyle shall not be allowed in
sex education
curriculum section six proposes that any
inclusion of sex education material
other than what is considered
predominant appeal for ordinary
adults will be a violation and shall be
considered an infraction and subject to
disciplinary
action a proposal to make it unlawful to
provide sex education about
lgbtq plus is in
itself
discriminatory and violates in my
opinion RSA
354 wherein no person shall be subjected
to
discrimination in public school because
of their gender identity or sexual
Orient
orientation
LBGTQ plus
students
teachers
employees and
parents would be forced back into the
closet considered the
Unspeakable do you know how many we have
in sex education
curricula okay I don't see any reason
for this bill other than to further a
cruel and unjust agenda against the
LBGTQ
up lastly if I could just finish up
sexual orientation and gender identity
are not chosen
Lifestyles as is stated throughout the
bill we do not choose to be left-handed
or right-handed it's not a lifestyle the
continuation of this myth just goes to
show how much education is
needed thank you thank you are there
questions from the
committee not see any questions thank
you very much okay and we will close
this
hearing I have a copy of this if you
would like
it
yeah
we're going to take a five minute break
committee
Mar
never
agree
of
yes
than
us
you
okay I'm going to go ahead with the next
bill which is on the dock for this
morning it's HB 1473 relative to social
emotional learning in public schools I'm
going to advise everybody that we do
have an overflow room on the other side
of the hall filled with people want to
testify on this bill we have over 40
cards which we've received so I am going
to limit the time to 2 minutes at the
end of 2 minutes I'm going to turn your
mic off so you know just be aware 2
minutes is what we're allowing for
people to speak on also as done in other
committees if we hear the same
duplication over and over and over it's
already been communicated you can say I
Echo those previous cards that spoke out
and said this you don't have to go in
and repeat everything that's been
previously said so we're not trying to
eliminate your you know expressing your
opinions but if your opinion parallels
something that's previously been said
please identify that and let us know
that so we can get everybody heard today
that's our primary goal right here on
this committee so with that the way we
work is that the the prime sponsor is
entitled to speak more but I'm going to
limitate limit this to no more than 10
minutes we've gone much further than
that on some other bills uh where we're
going to do the uh limiting right here
um so welcome uh representative
sellers uh good morning and thank you uh
chairman lad and vice chair Celli and
also the education committee thank you
for taking the time to hear what I have
to say I'm representative of sellers
Grafton County district 18 I represent
the towns of Bristol Alexandria
Bridgewater Heen
Gren Dorchester orange Grafton Kanan and
Enfield even I have to think and
remember these because these are the 10
southern towns of Grafton County
approximately 177,000 residents and I'm
actually bringing this bill not for
myself but I as a resident or a voter it
is for myself but many of my
constituents have actually said please
do something with this all right and
you're going to hear a lot of testimony
and a lot of hot testimony where seal is
actually very helpful and useful in the
schools and I'm not doubting it isn't
but what I am going to be showing and
bringing forward is some information
that's saying I'm not sure a lot of the
folks in any of the districts uh uh of
our schools understand and know what
seal is and so therefore again seal uh
in is stands for social emotional
learning all right now you you you just
start with that alone and say what is
that you know what I don't even think
the school districts can Define it
because I'm not sure they know how to
opt in or opt out of it and just to
state that alone and before I go any
further I did offer an amendment which
44738 and the amendment is an OP out
situation instead of the actual bill
which is to cease use and not provide
any funds forcl at all so technically
the education committee can actually
have a choice and uh which which they
would like to choose either allow the
parents to opt out okay or they could
just cease using seal in our state Al
together now instead of me just trying
to um say everything duplicate that's
been said probably for years at this
point I just want to say as I started
diving into this probably a little over
six months ago and shame on me for not
knowing it before and then but uh I just
didn't um in that time one I got a list
of acronyms I'm telling I think the
school uh the districts actually have
more acronyms than the uh US US military
so and I had to make a list because I
was getting so confused of how many
acronyms there are out there all right
and the other thing I want to bring up
real quick is this is the test schooles
for Newfound for 2023 which is last year
is okay um and everybody thinks that
they're doing great and this is just one
District okay and we're just slightly
above the state average and when you
really get down to it they're only at 60
65% depending on what you which one
you're looking at EA
65% math it's uh uh 51% in uh science
there again it's at 40% and and going
back there because that means the other
half of what's failing so these are our
academics and they're thinking we're
doing wonderful in academics we're not
we're not doing wonderful and we're just
slightly above the state average so I
just wanted to point that out so in
front of you I actually gave a handout
here it says uh The Unexplained rise of
therapeutic education how uh social
emotional learning extends K through 12
education reach into students lives and
expands teachers roles all right I say
to that to you just on the front page
because one it has four key points and
I'm not going to read them because again
I'm trying to save some time I God this
thing would take hours to try to talk to
and figure out it's irritating to me
and you know how much time and trying to
figure this out but it does have
tentacles into everything it does touch
everything seal touches our lives every
single day so when they say at the
school well it's in everything you know
what yeah it is in everything but we
need to Define it we need to figure this
out because it's not right for our kids
so I passed this out to you so you can
see those fo points but here I just want
to I I want to read a couple things here
off to you which is again
I I'm not going to recreate the wheel
all over again I'm just going to read
some this person puts it just right the
Bland uh pseudo science in somewhat incr
inscrutable term social and emotional
learning grafted onto the academic
effort of schooling mask its nature all
right think about that for a minute
they're saying it's all about academics
but it's all about social emotional
learning and now I'm going to put the
key on social emotional learning is
mental health and that's what they're
trying to do now with the schools is
provide mental health not for the 16%
that need it but for the 100% of the
kids in our schools and the 16% I'm
citing is from Nami
nmi National Alliance for mental illness
they stated
16% actually have mental illnesses each
year or a year for the kids so this is
coming from them all right right and and
I'm not trying to be come across as UNP
uh compassionate I'm very compassionate
I'm very concerned about these kids and
out their education all right and so
therefore I may sound like I'm heartless
but I'm not I'm very very very concerned
uh another quote here from this uh this
article and that's why I gave you the
top sheet of that you can easily just
that uh the uh part of that the uh title
into the web and you can easily get the
article yourself it's about 12 pages and
uh there's many many more articles you
can find but here's another one he says
uh this person he says there is an
obvious risk of viewing entire
classrooms as stalked with children
traumz
traumatized by definition all right St
with children traumatized by definition
all right because we just went through
covid so you know when you have 100%
technically going and having mental
illnesses I mean now they got to try to
weed this out all right and to try to
weed that out they actually use the uh
another framework which they call
mts-based
the doe you can get it there as far as
uh total information but what that does
is provide a framework work again with
three levels or three tiers of mental
health so they're trying to group the
kids into three levels you're okay yeah
you might need some help you definitely
need some help okay now they're getting
there because they're collecting data on
the kids all right they you can't figure
this out unless you collect data and how
you collect data is you do you do U uh
surveys and assessments all right and
now on those surveys and assessments are
some very private information that goes
back into the family goes right back
into your household all right so those
things even though they are getting
consent they are now collected the data
it's in the data system of the school
all right at that point but they're also
using Keen state they're passing some of
that if not all of that data to Keen
State because Keen state is looking at
the data as a whole and trying to say
hey this District this District needs
this this one has that and so on they
might not be given the actual CH child's
name but they're still passing the data
all right at that point
um so the data is a big thing it it's
you know how you he cash is King data is
King all right data is King this day and
age so I just here's here's one part I'm
going to read and then it's I'm going to
wrap it up all right um and these are
questions these are the questions
gentleman asks it says
by what right does the government
establish uh a um I'm going to need to
get my glasses on this sorry about
that I thought I could read it without
the glasses
but
again
okay says but what right does the
government established approved mindsets
to be in calculated in children next
question by what right does it deputize
minimally trained Personnel I mean it
minimally minimally trained Personnel
they're not psychologist they're
minimally trained Personnel they are not
psychologist to measure children's
adoption to these mindsets and
memorialize their process progress in
the uh internally Loosely data system
but what right does it employs such
immature mental assessments to set
children on the road to
overdiagnose overdiagnose think about
that this could actually lead to
medicines as well over diagnose and
perhaps
overmedication with potentially harm
harmful uh psychotropic drugs but what
right does the government wield these
techniques not to generally educate
children to fulfill their dreams but to
mold them it's the child's psyche their
changeing the mind we just heard some
the indoctrination
a teacher teaches it's a teaching it's a
tool it's indoctrination all right so
these are techniques to generally
educate children to fulfill their dreams
but to mold them into the kind of human
beings it deems more useful for the you
are done your time all right and the
last question all right and uh useful
Workforce and service to the state and
by what right does it have any of these
uh without notifying or potentially
notifying or uh obtaining cons uh
consent and so on so any I'll leave it
there like I said this could go on for
hours and I apologize for even run over
in 10 minutes boy 10 minutes goes fast
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question so
this whole issue of social emotional
learning is kind of hard I think for a
lot of people to wrap their heads around
because it's a methodology that seems to
infiltrate a lot of different things can
you give one clear example of um how a
teacher just from your experience what
you've heard an example of how a teacher
in a classroom would Implement some um
sure social emotional learning and how
that would reflect what uh is what you
consider wrong with it okay so let's
let's take for an example a math
question all right um here's the
question Johnny's mom and dad are
bringing Johnny to a fair which is 50
mil away they have a travel 20 miles how
many miles left all right simple it's a
math question for for I don't know
second third grade whatever it would be
right what they do is the teacher not in
all cases but in some and it depends on
the teacher all right instead of getting
into the math question they'll get into
the well Johnny has Mom and Dad how do
you all feel about that do you all have
mom and dads they're asking the kids
question so getting the kids involved
this way all right and then they say do
you think it's right to have two moms or
two dads or you know Mom and Dad or
whatever right so they're talking about
that and then the next thing they're
talking about is saying well how many
year you went to the faar you know and
then the next thing they go said well
why didn't you go and some say well I
couldn't afford it and they said well
you think that's right and and then so
they're getting into all that psych
stuff and getting the uh the kids
technically I'd say worked up because
you could say no well I'm sorry you
couldn't afford it so now they're
getting in to equality saying well you
should have been able to go so everybody
should be able to go so that's one
example and that's probably a decent one
I can are there further questions from
the committee representative Miler thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative sellers for being here
I'm
confused
um your your comments were basically
focused on your original
Bill I'd like to have you focus on your
replacement bill and if I read your
replacement bill your amendment is
primarily focused on Gathering of data
not on the teaching of seal is that
correct so it um we the commissioner
thought when I was speaking with the
commissioner thought that this would be
the best place to put that in and so it
would be for the opt out part but also
at the very bottom of the bill he also
suggested this is the identification or
definition of it which is the definition
that's used in Castle
cael which is almost a mantra that every
school district's using and by the way
we're only 37 school districts in our
state is using this right now only 37
out of I think what
182 but if I to
clarify the amendment deals with the
Gathering of information not the
teaching of seel
correct that's your intent that is where
it is in here you're right and and what
they're doing in the teaching because
every teacher is and I said let's put
back every staff member our staff
members eventually if they're not doing
it yet they're going to be is providing
input to
the call it the scoring system which
will actually create a level one two a
three tier so it is dater at that point
it all comes it all comes back to
data further questions I'm sorry it's it
is a lot there and I I'm not trying to
confuse representative cordelli uh thank
you representative sellers um uh in your
introduction you said that seal touches
everything and you brought up even a
math example um but in the
amendment um you're talking about the
provision of social emotional
learning
um and that no student should be
required to uh take a survey or
questionnaire or the provision of social
emotional learning so are you talking
about saying that that social emotional
learning cannot be um taught as in your
original
Bill isn't that what you're indicating
in the amendment as well and if and if
you are saying that it touches
everything and that there has to be
noticed in advance to the parent when
it's going to be provided I don't see
how how do you provide notice um of
someone introducing something that you
define as social emotional learning in a
math class I'm not sure how that all
works okay so first of all the yes words
absolutely matter provision would I need
to go back and look up the word and the
definition of it because that's what I
like to do with this that's what I've
learned as being a legislator look up
every word and what it
means but at this point here the the
uh
it's simple enough ask the school what
it means you know why why can't the
school identify this I mean I'm saying
it's in everything they should be able
to identify
it further
questions represent Damon thank you Mr
chair thank you for take my
question so if seal is in everything as
times I guess I need some clarity on
how are our wonderful trained
professional Educators would remove it
from
everything and still teach
children so the the example I gave you
on the math problem they don't have to
do that they can just teach the math go
back into the academics itself and and
spend more time in the academic part of
it instead of actually the story part of
it and that's that's one part they can
right very quickly please
so in the original
Bill your uh definition of social
emotional learning lines 5 through
12 you I just want to hear confirmation
that I'm understand this
correctly you would
oppose a staff person in a
school providing encouragement
motivation suggesting to a student that
they have enough grit to persevere with
something that's hard for them to do so
again um I'm not looking for the common
sense to be ripped out I mean that truly
is common sense at that point but the
lines 5 through 12 like you're saying uh
self-awareness self-management social
awareness relationship skills in
relation responsible decision- making
that comes from the castle website all
right this is their Mantra that they're
following and this is part of the stuff
that we're saying does not need to be
taught are there further questions
represent beler thank you Mr chair and
thank you for bringing this forward um I
think a lot of people were surprised
when you mentioned um this idea that a
teacher might go kind of off topic in a
math equation to talk about other things
social things things and I my question
for you is are you aware that that the
official name for that such a thing is
called generative themes that is part of
fre and pedagogy that is taught at most
uh universities and colleges of
country well no no I'm not aware of that
I can't say I am and and I'll have to
admit I I I'm just Joe the plumber I'm
not the uh PhD doctorate on in education
so thank you further questions from the
committee represent McDonald thank you
Mr chair good morning
representative I'm looking specifically
at the amendment online 23 where social
emotional learning includes
self-awareness self-management and I
understand you said you got that
definition from somewhere else but I'm
thinking of the word social and kind of
a student interacting with other
students so these self-reflective
Concepts does that include things such
as time management such as you have a
homework assignment due let's try to
figure out how to time manage and get
this homework assignment done is that
included in social emotional learning
are you saying time management you
saying like that again that would be
just common sense you would why why are
we throwing Common Sense out the window
that that's not that's not necessary
represent thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I believe in
your testimony you said that social
emotional learning has tentacles
everywhere and I'm curious how a parent
would possibly be able to opt out if
it's
everywhere that's where the school
district or the Department of Education
someone needs to identify this we're
trying to identify it in in in the
original um bill lines 5 through 12 at
that point but you know the the general
def uh definition of
um yeah the definition is is the selfa
witness self-manager you know social
wellness and again you have to go back
to the castle website which actually
says this is what each one means so I
guess if you can say okay if we can box
that in then you can have an opt out
situation at that point all right I can
only tell you I was at my uh delivered a
session this last Saturday and we were
talking about seal because it was part
of the budget and everything else at
this point and and many people didn't
even know what SEO was and or the
acronym at all and so on so I mean this
is like how the anybody knows about this
and it's yet it's it digs deep and it's
in going into the into the psyche of the
child and it is teaching the child
certain aspects beyond what the family
should be teaching the child and I think
it's usurping the family but hopefully I
answer that as far as definition it
really comes up to maybe someone someone
coming out and forcing this
definition representative cascaden thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative for your presentation uh
my question is the story that you relate
or the example you relate did you
yourself observe that in a classroom or
did you use that story to um explain
your point uh no I try to observe
anything in the classroom this day you
can't get in the door um you know even
though it's public we call it a public
school you can't you get in there this
came from a video I actually watched as
an example how they're using it someone
must have at one time have seen this and
a lot of some of the stuff I related to
and talked about is from a a video here
a video there and even going back and
just going on one other thing is even
the department new uh New Hampshire
Department of Education
had a video on consent they were talking
about to counselors and uh in Keen State
and even they couldn't figure out should
we uh should we call the parents or
should we uh text the parents a or email
the parents a consent form in this case
in that case they're confused they don't
even know when to do it and and and
these are counselors from different
school district and the New Hampshire
doe putting on the on the hearing it's
it's out there for people to see
thank you very much are there further
questions from the committee not seeing
any thank you very much thank you all
and I do really appreciate time I know
how busy one more
question go ahead you represent you're
done uh so Mr chair thank you I need I
need a clarification from the chair we
have two issues before us we have the
original 1473 as introduced now we have
before the committee the
amendment which is different than the
original and the question to you Mr
chair is our Focus as a committee on the
amendment or the original Bill the
amendment can't be taken up by the
committee until a member on the
committee in an executive session put
that Amendment forward so we're
basically still on the bill as it was
introduced although you bring up a good
point that I'm going to have copies of
this amendment made uh if Jennifer for
is listening to me somewhere I don't see
her in the back of the room she's in the
room she's in the other room if she
could come and we'll give this amendment
to her um in testimony uh represent
seller you say
7473 it's 7437 is that
correct okay so we'll get copies of this
amendment made and put forward on on the
table over they're placed on a table so
folks that are looking to get it or
0437 h of course it starts out with
2024 do you have a clean copy I'll go
give it to Jennifer yeah back to
Jennifer so with that we're going to go
ahead and I'm going to call two
names the in case that the one of these
people may be in the other room so so
it's just like baseball who's up and
who's on Deck who's in the hole so so
Mary steady you're up and Lenny O'Keefe
Deck two minutes and and we have
absolutely two minutes for cutting off
in two
you
honorable members of the House Education
committee thank you for listening to me
today my name is Dr Mary steady and I've
spent 30 years supporting students from
vulnerable backgrounds in their families
after the heartbreaking Sandy Hook event
I worked tily in New Hampshire to set up
ways to keep our students and their
families safe from such tragedies by the
development and the creation of the
Bureau of student wellness and nutrition
within the Department of Education this
bill I'm afraid is a big step back from
all the work as it fundamentally
undermines the substantial progress we
have made in fostering student wellness
and creating nurturing educational
environments today I am before you to
share my strong opposition of proposed
House Bill
1473 which seeks to prohibit us from
teaching our kids how to be strong and
good people ready to do great things for
our community in trying to understand
the underlying message of this bill it
became increasingly clear to me that
this legisl in question is not just
impractical illogical but indeed B
borders on the
ludicrous this brings me to the real
elephant in the Rome this bill seems
less about supporting and nurturing our
children and more about the profound and
troubling Trend the active dismantling
of public education system we need to
ask our legislators is this legislators
is this bill really just another attempt
to gut part of the educational system so
will cease to exist getting rid of
doesn't just tweak a few things it
actively interferes with RSA 93 J
Suicide Prevention and RSA 193f pupil
safety these laws make sure our schools
are places where kids can feel safe and
don't have to worry about getting hurt
or bullied seal teaches kids how to
handle their feelings sort out problems
be kind and wel welcoming to everyone
moreover this bill proposes a direct
challenge to the objectives in RSA
1359 system of care law which
prioritizes early identification and
intervention in addressing student
mental health issues a vital
collaborative effort between the New
Hampshire Department of Education and
the New Hampshire Department of Health
and Human Services I urge the committee
on to reflect on the significant
ramifications of this bill
thank you thank you very much questions
from the
committee not not seeing thank you very
much uh like to invite uh Lenny o'keef
De good morning thank you for letting me
talk uh my name is Lenny 'keep and I
work for the conquer Police Department
in a civilian role I work in the
community service unit
this is a a comfort dog Liberty this
Liberty was the first Comfort dog in the
state of New Hampshire and part of what
we do is we we visit kids in school and
and take take help with activities in
school and so on so um about three years
ago I was in school and a principal was
explaining uh choose love and that's the
only Seal program that I know about is
the Choose Love movement uh to his
parents of what Choose Love was and
after listening to him for about 10
minutes I called the Choose Love love
number and hooked up with choose love
and I was able to uh the next day meet
with Scarlett Lewis who is the mother
from Sandy Hook who created the Choose
Love movement after that I got to Tour
the State of New Hampshire um for a
whole year with Scarlet Liberty myself
with scarlet and we did Choose Love
activities at these schools um just want
to tell you one quick story about one of
the schools we visited so um in
Charlotte in Charlotte's program she
talks about forgiveness and children
learn about forgiveness and this is
coming from mother who lost her son in a
school shooting and she talks about how
forgiveness has helped her because she
was able to cut the cord from herself to
the school shooter and it eased her
anxiety um it freed her from the school
shooter so we're talking about
forgiveness at a school um in Southern
New Hampshire and a third grader had
written down what we called was a
forgiveness basketball they write down
something they want to forgive and they
throw it in a b garbage can so that's
they're cutting the cord they're
forgiving they're it's no longer on
their mind they're able to move on so
one of the teachers picked the piece of
paper up because the little boy was
really really you could tell the little
boy was excited and he was relieved so
after the little boy walked away we read
the paper the paper said I forgive my
dad for being mad at me last night
because I didn't play well in the hockey
game so if you want to talk about
academics that day if that little boy
didn't forgive his dad that little boy
is not learning anything that day you
know he was able to take that
forgiveness and throw it away and then
he went on with his day but before that
that's what was on his mind was that he
didn't play well in a hockey game last
night so I have never heard that
question asked I visited a hundred
schools probably in the state of New
Hampshire thank you very much your time
is up okay and your dog does behave well
she is good not like the puppy that we
have that's 10 weeks old and I'll trade
you
yeah any questions represent
Damon I would like you to invite you to
bring your dog here for House Education
Comm day it's funny we have testified
here several times but it's never been
the education part so represent beler
you have a question I D thank you Mr
chair and thank you for your testimony
you mentioned this this um activity of
undertaking forgiveness and throwing
throwing the ball and and doing that um
can you can you cite for me any sort of
any evidence or anything else based in
you know actual tested methodology that
concludes that that's effective and
going to work and there's no side
effects or any other problems with with
getting into that sort of thing in
school I can't I can only tell you what
I witnessed that day and and like I said
not just that day we visited we went
from Berlin we've been all the way to
Salem to Nashville I can't even count
the number of schools that me and
Liberty have been in with Scarlet so
thank you further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
Deck
hello good morning good
morning I want to take a minute and just
say thank you for giving the opportunity
to come and speak here today um I'm the
principal and special education director
at Spalding Academy and family services
and I've worked there for the last 24
years and we serve the most difficult
children in the state the children that
can't have their needs met in a public
school setting these are the kids that
cost districts $100,000 a year to
educate they send them to us cuz they're
simply not successful and they're not
safe in a public school setting these
are the kids that come to school and
they cry in the counselor's offices they
don't feel safe they're bullied it's our
job to meet their emotional needs they
don't all have parents at home that are
positive mail or role models to help
them process the complexity of the
feelings that they have right now we
introduced social motion learning in uh
202 22 and since we did that our all of
our students are tier three students
when you refer to
mtss um we've had students that have
decreased their behavioral referrals
from 18 a month to one from 13 a month
to one we've had children that refus to
go to school who attended School 56% of
the time 47% of the time 0% and 0% of
the time prior to their placement these
same children now come to school 90%
100% 9 9% and 100% of the time it's
because we make a cognizant effort to
address their social and emotional needs
we make them feel safe because they're
attending school and their behavioral
referrals are down their academics are
going through the roof prior to social
emotional learning in a districtwide
assessment of neoa 46% of them met
projected growth after a year that was
up to 62% and our brilliant resilient
children jumped that to 72% this winter
so that's a 26% increase by taking away
some academic time in the morning and
meeting their needs socially and
emotionally they walk through their
front door this was important enough
that Governor sonunu established a a
position and Shannon's run that for the
last couple years meeting the diverse
needs of our children our our adults
throughout the state um I think we're
doing a great dishonor by even
discussing this it feels negligent to
even have the words come out of my mouth
that we're going to take SE away our
kids that can't read we would thank you
very much your time is up that's that's
quick it does go by doesn't it yeah
there is a there is a question for you
though sure I got one for you too you're
Garrett right yes sir we have another
card Tory Benjamin also from
Spalding Paul Tom oh that's Tom oh yeah
he's not a student we haven't Tau him
handwriting
yet okay go go ahead with a question
Miley thank you Mr chair and thank you
for the work you do with your children
that you work you're welcome it's an
honor I I have I have two questions sure
uh the number of students that you're
working with on a daily basis and could
you explain a little bit about what the
Seal program has what are the components
of it that has provided such uh positive
results for the students that you work
with thank you yeah absolutely so we
have 76 uh children in our school right
now and uh seal is a focus on
self-awareness self-management
responsible decision making social
awareness and responsible decisions the
curriculum that we're using is the
Choose Love curriculum which um Scarlet
Lewis started after the Sandy Hook
Massacre and um so that focuses on
teaching our children to have courage to
show gratitude to show forgiveness and
to show compassion and action and we
spend about 45 minutes to an hour every
morning before the kids start their
academic day EXP licitly teaching these
skills just like we would teach children
how to
read what what grade what grade what
grade level are you dealing with we
serve children from 5 to 22 years of age
really across the spectrum of learning
disabilities than you're welcome further
questions from the committee yes
represent mcdonal thank you Mr chair
good morning thank you for being here
for everything my question is you're the
second speaker speaker to have mentioned
the Choose Love program are you aware of
any other programs that are included
under seal um I I'm not aware of any
other curriculum Castle also has
curricular materials we've really
partnered with um Shannon from the state
of New Hampshire and Scarlet to bring
choose love to to our school thank you
you're welcome further questions thank
Deck good morning my name is uh Tom
Benjamin and I work with it over at
Spalding and in my two minutes I guess I
just want to share going back to the
original bill whyel is so important in
my opinion is that that bill even exists
and what I've learned throughout the
years we're going to educate the kids we
either do it directly or they're going
to get their own education so what we're
trying to do and what the research has
said is that without explicit
instruction means direct instruction
just like math they're not going to get
the social tional skills that we want
them to have this is a religious a
political um the example that was given
this morning yeah maybe that was
observed but that's not something we
would do at our school saying oh that's
too bad in the middle of your friends
you don't have a family that you know
that just absolutely would never occur
now my big thing I don't know this
except for speculation we have some of
the toughest kids in the state all right
we work with the toughest kids in the
state and I have a strong belief we can
reset their trajectory so one of my my
loved ones doesn't get hurt by them
Andor we can keep them out of prison at
$56,000 a year in the state of New
Hampshire I mean you're going to be
paying for it one way or
another um and then what's my
little and then I guess the last thing
which kind of goes along with this
Harvard has been doing a study that
lasts approximately 75 years it's the
longest longitudal study in the country
and it's on uh happiness and the number
one thing that they discovered and have
repeatedly discovered with happiness is
relationships those people who have
evaluated themselves to say I have a
strong relationship so the same people
who record themselves as having the
highest degree of Happiness we work with
kids from very very very difficult
places who have been to Hell him back
not through their own choice and we let
them know that they're loved every day
how could we not I mean you know cuz I
keep saying oh let forgive my dad well
we've got kids who would said because
but the dad you know beat me up last
night those are the kids that we work
with I'm talking about a second
grader thank you very much are there
questions of Mr
benman yes represent dry thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here um so
i' I've heard today that this is
incorporated kind of into everything in
schools and yet you have a specific time
set a aside to do it during the day is
that where you teach a specific
curriculum and then use it during the
rest of the day right there are multiple
curriculum somebody ask there's like
second step um skill stream so there's
different social we use Choose Love and
so there are units so yeah we teach the
units so like today was on forgiveness
and then the kids and and I guess the
other thing I just stressed we have the
staff practices too because maybe some
of our staff are coming from difficult
places so we're all in it together um
and so there's a specific lesson that's
done for the week and then we carry it
through throughout the school day um
like I learned a lot about courage you
know courage it takes courage to forgive
somebody this is the lesson this morning
it takes courage to forgive somebody who
hasn't said they're
sorry thank you very much further
questions thank you very much for doing
what are you for represent
leus in Choose Love do you have to um
take surveys of your kids analyze your
kids collect data that kind of stuff in
that particular
program do you have to I mean is that
part of the program yes well we have to
collect data because of the regulations
that we have to operate under so like
Garrett was talking about our incident
reports are really behavioral referrals
so we use that as our Benchmark are we
headed in the right direction if we're
not we change what we're doing but as
far as the particular program that's not
part of the program that of I don't know
yeah I don't they have a formal data
collection piece with the choose
okay least not that I'm aware of thank
you very much further questions thank
you very much and thank you for what you
do at Spalding several of us made a trip
to Spalding must have been eight nine
years ago as a committee and appreciate
what you all do over there um like to
have uh enry Banfield followed by
Nicholas Duffy who is on Deck from the
New Hampshire Department of
Corrections not you
Amry thank you for that clarification
andry B fail parental rights advocate in
New Hampshire um I do support the
amendment not the original bill I do I
want to make that very clear uh I think
that the the amendment is just directed
at parental consent which is something
that every seal person in this room and
in our school should be doing already um
by law by federal law that's
required um some of the problems that
and and I'm going to turn written
testimony I hope that you'll go through
it because I'm going to have to shorten
it
um some of the problems is is that uh it
creates standards and attitudes and
values and beliefs and dispositions this
is what the state would have to do
teachers have always supported children
social emotionally and I think that
we're trying to look at what they've
always done and what seal has done is
it's
standardized it is now um also a data
collector it assess
children but that you know in the past
teachers have always tried to do this in
the class room um it scores at child's
attitudes values beliefs and
dispositions in a subjective way that's
why I received a call from a teacher in
New Hampshire who is having to grade her
children uh her students um attitudes
and values and the problem with that was
that she had kids in the in the public
school and she was concerned about their
her kids' teachers also grading their
values and
attitudes uh it it appears to be that um
who received use the personal data once
once this information is
collected uh just 1473 as amended would
just affirm the ethical treatment of
children when they are assessed or
receiving Mental Health
Services um in Essa under uh I I think
when you look at this it it gives you a
link in Essa it does require parental
consent when servicing or assessing a
student's mental health so this is
something that they should already be
doing but I can tell you that they're
not because I've done rights and no
requests looking for parental consent
forms on some of these assessments and
they've provided no um consent form so
obviously they're not doing that we're
at the end of the two minutes okay all
right I've got quite a bit more but uh
are there questions for emry if you have
written testimony please submit that and
we'll be put up as part of the record
not see any questions thank you very
much I'd like to invite Nicholas Duffy
thank you for allowing me to testify
today my name is Nick Duffy I am the
director of rehabilitative services for
the New Hampshire Department of
Correction part of my role is also
overseeing the correction Special School
District for the New Hampshire
Department of directions and um that's
how uh we're attached to this bill is um
is with we're School District so social
emotional learning is something that we
also teach within our schools we
partnered with um Shannon scarlet and
choose love um to develop a program for
the New Hampshire Department of
Corrections however this is also in our
other programs um there's thinking for a
change there's more recognation therapy
and and others that um that we also do
um that teaches social emotional
learning skills
um and so an example some of the topics
that are learned in our programs and
courses include active compassionate
listening growth mindset how to deal
with stress how to appropriately
disagree forgiveness gratitude
self-awareness re resiliency healthy
assertiveness um and how to have
difficult conversations to name a few
these are all skills that not only are
going to help individuals with
relationships but these are job skills
we need these they need these skills in
order to to get employment and
effectively keep employment um so
removing this would have a impact on
releasing individuals get them getting
jobs and having relationship with their
families um really their overall uh
well-being um we want people to leave
incarceration and not come back and um
we believe this would be a big step
backwards if we were to have to take
this out of our curriculums in education
thank you thank you very much uh
questions rep and dry thank you Mr
chairman thank you for coming yes um um
if we did the amendment when it was just
an opt out because of parental consent
would that affect what you are doing
yeah so I haven't looked at the
amendment um obviously I just heard
about it today but um I'm so not 100%
sure but it sounds like that it might
not affect us as much but I think a lot
of us have not seen that Amendment and
read it yeah represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony in your work with
what you do um And in regards to the
Choose Love movement in Seal is there a
uh restorative justice model or
framework being utilized in any of this
yeah so I think restorative justice is a
um is a big component of how we can um
work with victims with um with uh
restoring people back to their
communities and I think that um I'm not
sure I I would need to talk a little bit
more with you about exactly what you
mean by that but I think yes restorative
justice is something we want in in most
of our programs thank you thank you for
the questions from the committee
representative Miler thank you for being
here again could you define the
population that you're dealing with
please the population that we're doing
choose love with or program with yes so
we do this with our individuals who are
incarcerated with at the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections regardless of
age regardless of age further questions
thank you very much thank you like to
invite Sarah G followed by Stacy
Brooks
it good morning morning thank you thank
you all for having me and hearing my
testimony um I have a lot to say and so
I'm going to condense it into two
minutes um and I do a written testimony
with way more details so um uh thank you
chairman lad and honorable members of
the House Education committee for having
me and hearing my testimony my name is
Sarah G I am the uh training and program
manager at Connor's climb Foundation we
are a small nonprofit based in the Sea
Coast and we provide Suicide Prevention
education to schools in the community um
throughout New Hampshire we're here
today in opposition to this bill um we
we feel that this would hinder uh the
bill as introduced would hinder our
ability to provide the life-saving
evidence-based um inter uh life-saving
um program that we um assist schools in
um providing to students um we also have
questions as someone else mentioned
about the suicide prevention law that we
worked hard to to get into place as you
may may know or remember um and so uh
that law does require the 193 J2 does
require that Suicide Prevention
education happen um for staff and
students annually in schools we know
that the the bill as introduced is in
direct conflict with um the student
portion of RSA um 193 J2 and we have
questions about whether or not that
would affect the staff portion of that
bill of that law or not there was some
um language about professional
development so we're just not sure about
that um
and so um there's and you know the
program that we um assist schools with
um providing for their students is
evidence-based um students that um
engage in that program are 64 process uh
perc less likely to report that they
have attempted an attempted suicide so
we do believe that with without um
without this life-saving um program or
other Pro other evidence-based programs
like it um we will see an increase in
suicide death youth in New Hampshire and
it already is the second leading cause
of death so um other than that I can
thank you very much um I can answer any
questions if anyone has any thank you
gra
leus can you tell me thank you can you
tell me which program you're using sure
we use the SOS signs of suicide program
thank you further questions from the
committee representative dry thank you
and thank you for for coming to testify
I'm going to ask the same question I
just asked if if if we did the amendment
which just is an opt out program how
would that affect you so I actually I'm
not able to answer that question fully
because I haven't looked at the
amendment it came in like right before
it came up so um but I'm happy to read
it and get back to you I it sounds like
if it's an opt out it sounds like it
would not affect um it would not affect
what we do I mean there is a part to our
program that is a a survey and we that
is already optional for schools and it's
not our program I'm sorry we partner
with another organization to mind wise
Innovations but we we fund it in schools
in New Hampshire and um so the SOS
program does have a portion that is a a
survey and we schools know that that is
optional and schools do already if they
use it um get an opt in to to use that
per New Hampshire law already so thank
you very much further questions thank
you awesome thank you so much have a
good day uh I'd like to invite Stacy
Brooks and Nicole L and I'm going to try
to keep the questions down about the
amendment that's been passed out a lot
of folks have not read it and uh so I
don't think I'm prepared to even discuss
that myself because I haven't had the
opportunity so let's let's stick to
where we're going with the bill as it
was introduced uh Stacy Brooks welcome
long good morning my name is Stacy
Brooks I reside in Durham today I am
here to oppose HB 1473 I am a mother I'm
a former School Board member I was a
paraprofessional and a specialed
preschool program that Services
children's age three through three
through five that are coming off early
supports and services point of
order yes excuse me
Pro oh
sorry oh we're not all sorry
um uh I was par professional um for
eight years in a program that I had a
child attend he is now 25 years old and
I'm also the parent of a child who died
by
Suicide
um the new Futures website says when I
did research I didn't realize how many
people would be here from different
organizations that social emotional
learning skills help children build
healthy relations succeed in school and
future workplaces and contribute to our
communities today students spend the
majority of their days in the classroom
and as they get older in school related
activities like team sports and clubs
everything from drama to journalism to
volunteer work in order to succeed in
school our students need to be
physically emotionally and mentally
available um I'm going to skip a little
bills like this pit families against
schools it should not be that way it
does it does after all take a village
this is not a New Concept to me social
skills is Mr Lee's third fourth grade
classroom cheering when the kids in his
class wanted to see if they could answer
a multiplication fact faster than my son
could identify a number on a flash card
it was a goal that he was learning to
identify numbers at the time um and then
cheering when my son was faster each kid
wanting to take a turn not to beat him
but to see him succeed it is those same
kids that stood and cheered loudly and
long when he walked across the
graduation
stage um and if not for anything but do
you want to know the most po the the
best team at any High School it is the
Unified sports team because that's where
the kids come together your time is up
sorry thank you I do want to thank all
of the different or organizations and
associations that have come to support
this bill especially Suicide Prevention
and education we appreciate your coming
as well thank you uh questions from the
committee thank you very much okay uh
Phillips good morning good morning hello
my name is Nicole long and I'm a school
counselor well I'm astounded to help to
defend the importance of social
emotional learning to continue to be
embedded within our schools I thank you
for this opportunity to speak today
social emotional learning has become a
Paramount component of the New Hampshire
education system in 2022 the national
survey for children Health noted that
30.3% of New Hampshire youth had one or
more emotional Behavioral or
developmental conditions
34.6% of grandate children and their
families had stated that it was very
difficult to receive the mental health
treatment or counseling that they needed
and 29.9% of those children were either
bullied picked on or excluded by other
children school should be a place of
safety belonging compassion security and
nurture where students can foster
relationships amongst their peers and
adults and feel connected and heard
students can honor the beauty of
developing a growth mindset and taking
moments of mistakes opportunities to
grow whether that be academically or
socially emotionally our young people
unequivocally know that there's a
support system ring behind them and
cheering them on to encourage their
resiliency through challenges and to PVE
a better and bright future for
themselves the whole child is the
priority and it's not defined by their
academic performance their adverse
childhood experiences or trauma does not
define their identity it's clear that
there's a mental health crisis of for
our youth and it's one of the many
challenges that are impacting New
Hampshire amilies prohibiting social
emotional learning from embedded into
the New Hampshire education system would
only exacerbate these deficits and
significant needs for our young gr
Staters and their families life can be
hard and over the past few years we've
certainly seen unforeseen challenges
between horrific tragedies through our
country and a pandemic that's left
Everlasting
impacts I've seen firsthand the
importance of social emotional learning
within the functionality of our school
culture every single day it aids is a
resourceful to tool for not only our
students but for the collaborative and
development of stronger family and
Community Partnerships most importantly
while this may sound drastic I have seen
save young children's lives we owe it to
our students to create a school
environment where their future can shine
bright and be given endless
opportunities to grow in all
developmental areas learning is a
relational process students need to
maslo before they can bloom it's human
instinct to have our basic needs met and
essential to recognize that before
academic youred thank you so much for
the opportunity to speak today if you
have written testimony there we'll be
pleased to put that into the whole thing
in the record I will thank you are there
any questions yes represent
leus thank you for answering my question
sure can you tell me what Pro if there's
a program and what program you use yeah
absolutely so um we have used various
different programs we've used the second
step program that's evidence-based
driven that someone has mentioned prior
to this we've used and choose love as
well there's also the ruler
evidence-based program there's path
program there's an emotional ABC program
that's geared towards preing
kindergarten students that's more
interactive and made for their skills
that levels um so there's a wide R um
that students can choose from schools
that meet their needs follow up um U
well I'd rather only go with one
question now a lot of cards to go here
represent belra had his hand up also
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony yeah so uh the term
social emotional learning was coined by
an organization called the Fetzer
Institute which for refers to itself as
scientific spirituality they spun off
Castle um Choose Love says they are
aligned with castle and they teach
mindfulness can you give us a little bit
of information and specifics as to where
that line is between things like
mindfulness and spirituality sure so
mindfulness is more of the grounding
method that you can use within a school
so if a student is feeling disregulated
or stressed you can have them use a
mindfulness skill of taking a deep
breath using Vis visualization um of a
place that brings them Cal place that
brings them Zen where they can um reset
reregulate to to be able to proceed
moving forward so it's not pushing
forward any spirituality or religion per
se it's really having a student be
regulatory towards what their needs are
if I from this point onwards I'm just
going to allow one question from
committee members and that's going to be
it uh representative Miler thank you Mr
chair and thank you for the service
you're doing the students that you're
working with thank you my question is
this in your experience as a counselor
yeah over the last several years what
has been the change
in the needs of the students that you're
dealing
with there are a lot of changes I would
say from our society in general various
different um perspective and opinions a
lot of the tragedies and a lot of the
the pandemic have made a lot of
difficulties for our families they
cannot access the resources that they
need they look to the schools for
support whether that be for day-to-day
um basic needs of clothing food or
whether they need um you know more of
that explicit skills being taught they
really look to the schools for that
support every single day thank you
representa Cornell thank you and thank
you as a retired 36- year middle school
guidance counselor I know what your day
is like but you did say embedded in
curriculum and school culture so I'm
assuming this is something that
schoolwide embedded in the curriculum
School culture can mean a lot of things
but it's not taking time out from the
day from learning to read and do math
math and Core Curriculum uh some
components of the day may have an
advisory or a morning meeting that can
be a quick 10 to 15 minute component of
a check-in with a student teachers can
say hey how are you just to get a pulse
of what they may need that basic needs
component right um but it doesn't uh
take up a lot of time when you think
about if a student walks in the door
disregulated and they can't function it
really gives them that opportunity to
reset with the people they trust the
most to then be able to be able to learn
that school day thank you very much
thank you for the question any new
questions thank you very much for coming
today thank you so much for having me uh
Deck thank you Linda Phillips of Bristol
um I've been a um adopted parent and a
foster parent and I had more training in
those classes than our teachers do in um
expounding the virtues of cell um um
it's very invasive it it encompasses
everything there's no boundaries and
teaching it can include anything from
who did you have sex with to uh
gender identity issues most parents are
concerned about the
unregulated access teachers
have they're they're concerned about the
promotion of ideological and political
ends that are easily SL slipped into
sell practices the displacement of
academic Vigor the expectation of
teachers to act as therapist with
minimal training and unqualified
additional budget cost that cannot be
accounted by direct means because it
infiltrates every aspect of the school
day untrained teachers are allowed to
probe into student psyches promoting a
holistic schema through which they can
children can comprehend their family and
their friend relationships medical
ethics prohibits practice by unlicensed
and untrained individual ual but that
doesn't stop anyone puts local school
district at risk for educational
malpractice or lawsuits software hacks
such as what has occurred at the
Newfound sa4 last year heightens the
security concerns and the privacy of the
families with the ongoing weekly monthly
data collection process it doesn't stay
within the district it goes to another
organization that gives out the grant
money and it's spread all over the state
and the questions are asked of the
students how much do you weigh how tall
are you who was the last person you had
sex with have you ever been identified
as having a an STD uh are you
questioning your gender um is someone in
your home depressed or has anxiety how
often do you eat potato salad and
carrots kind of thing invasive questions
your time is up with the families thank
you for letting me speak if you have
written testimony be glad to put that in
the okay thank you very much any
questions from the committee thank you
Jessica
Bickford and Jillian
Deck good morning thank you for your
time this morning my name is Jess
Bickford and I'm assistant
superintendent I've seen many of you
several times um so I would like to
focus most of my testimony on the
potential violation for idea and RSA
186c that this bill would cause so
through the special ed process teams
make decisions regarding programming
goals assessments things like that that
are prescribed by those teams including
parent consent and those are mandated by
federal and state law this bill would
essentially violate that not allowing
for a lot of those self-regulation
self-help Behavioral Management
strategies and practices and curriculums
that go with that that the team have
identified is a must need for that
student to make progress along with that
comes Public Funding even if they end up
in a private school like Spalding or
some other Institute that the team feels
is necessary for that child to get their
needs met um so this bill would also
violate those rights of those students
and the funding that would go to those
private entities because they are
publicly funded through the special
education process uh I also oppose the
amendment that is made particularly in
regards to lines 6 through 99 because it
does not qualify that it is a survey of
the provision of social emotional
learning it says the provision of social
emotional learning not the data
collection or survey of we already have
rules in place to uh allow parents to
opt out um and schools to notice parents
when we give surveys like that I've
heard testimony today regarding the ybs
survey which is a lot of those social
emotional type questions parents already
have the right to
relinquish or not let their child
participate in those surveys so I think
it would be redundant to include that uh
in any of these bills thank you thank
you very much are there questions for
the
superintendent thank you all right thank
you uh Jillian uh Duo and followed by
Mary
daughter
welcome thank you honorable chair lad
and members of the committee my name is
Jillian Andrews Duo and I'm a mom of two
including my daughter Cordelia who's
here with me today um she's going to be
testifying after me uh her testimony is
her own words although we did work
together to make it a little more
concise nice and
organized um I'm also a former social
studies teacher and a person who has
struggled with her mental health since
adolescence I'm asking you today to
please find uh hb1
1473 itl either in the current format or
with the amendment um I also wanted to
disclose that I do work for new Futures
but I'm here today to represent myself
because this topic is so important to me
um I also want to mentioned that it's
important to uh a lot of folks around
the state uh more than uh 3,300 folks
signed in in opposition to this bill um
in the online
portal um let's see so Cordelia has been
able to take classes and they've been
really wonderful for helping her
recognize her emotions and manage her
big feelings um you know it's this isn't
something that's separating schools from
families it's something that we can work
on together uh she's going to show you
the toolbar that they have taught and
like this is something that I already
had printed out at home before I even
heard that this bill existed because it
was something that we're trying to work
on and extend her learning at at school
to uh to home
um and uh they also do the Choose Love
program which you've heard a lot about
and it's really special part of her
school um you know I I think it's so
important that we focus on that part of
keeping kids safe because uh you know we
we can't turn our schools into prisons
and you know I don't think families want
that we can't afford it anyway um so
it's really important to keep our kids
safe in this way you're two minutes but
we haven't heard from Cordelia yet
minutes
honorable chead and members of the
committee my name is Cordelia Duo I'm 6
years old and in first grade at abot
Downing School my mom told me that there
could be a new role so kids couldn't
take social emotional learning orl
classes anymore I did not like that
because SEO class helps me stay calm and
be happier and kinder
in first grade we have SEO class every 6
days just like gym and music I like it
and so do other kids they taught me what
I could do when I got mad at school or
at home one thing they teach us is to
use the tool bar when you get
mad first you pause and
breathe that means you take three slow
deep
breath then you
rewind that means to think of about what
feeling last you play that means you
make a good
choice another thing we learned about is
breathing that means you trace up when
you breathe in on your finger and Trace
out we also got to go outside for some
of our time we learned about being kind
on the playground we had a really fun
Dutcher playworks class is also every
six days we Lear fun playground games
and how to be kind while we play it's
one of our favorite
classes we also learn about Choose Love
at school some of the parts of Choose
Love are courage and gratitude for
courage we made a sun and if a grown-up
ever saw you do something that was Brave
they'd give you a sticker and you'd put
it on the
sun gratitude means that you're thankful
for something we made a gratitude tree
everyone in the school made a leaf mine
said for my doll Caitlyn a bunch of
also the whole school learns about being
respectful it's one of the things on the
signs in the school it means to be kind
to others thank you for taking the time
to listen to what kids think about SEO
please vote against House Bill
Cordelia you're the youngest person ever
to testified in this committee
and we all need to take a deep breath
true and we're happy to take questions
okay are there any questions for
Cordelia no but thank you very much for
taking the time today to come in thank
you
Cordelia you you had one represent
Damon Cordelia I am so grateful for your
presence here and your mom's and I am
wondering if you have any thoughts about
what you want to be when you grow up I
want to have the same job as my mom
because then it would be easier for them
to teach me thank you
wow impressive thank you very much we'll
get our lobbyist badge
soon I say good luck to
Mom uh like to invite Mary wilky and
Freeman
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee thank you for hearing my
testimony and that's a tough act to
follow that's hard to
follow um I'm opposed to hb1 1473 um
underlying the bill is a is a deep
mistrust of teachers that is ironically
being fostered by bills like this the
sponsor of the bill provided no evidence
that teachers in New Hampshire are um
changing math question into questions
about U marital status or same-sex
marriage um in my experience teachers
are highly trusted I'm a retired teacher
I should have said public school teacher
and teachers are trusted and by parents
and um teachers deserve to be trusted
uh in fact often parents go to teachers
and ask them for help on these very
skills how how can I help my child have
more friends um what can I do how how
could my child has doesn't seem to have
a lot of self-control do you have any
advice about that teachers see so many
kids yes teachers are not psychologists
they have taken courses in child
psychology they know about child
development but they see so many
children that often parents just ask
them for that kind of advice I think
they are are trusted and they are worthy
of trust um the definition in this bill
is so broad that it's impossible to
comply whether it's the original bill or
the amendment um and I just would like
like to give a couple of examples maybe
some of you like me had first day
jitters the first day of school
especially going off to a new school
maybe Middle School maybe kindergarten
maybe high school and um so as a teacher
on those first days you do a lot of
games and activities to help kids get to
know each other feel comfortable with
you as the teacher they're all
non-cognitive they're all social and um
if we were going to not do that the
first day of middle school kids would
have walked into my CL math class I
would have said hello my is name is Miss
wil please sit down and get out your
math book that's not the way we treat
human beings that's how we would treat a
robot who was there to be fed some kind
of data um other examples are it those
bill says you know no you can't have
policies activities Etc about
self-management that means literally I
wouldn't be able to set an expectation
that you raise your hand before you
speak um relationship skills none of
that I can't talk about we couldn't have
a policy about bullying I know that
sounds common sense with say that's
ridiculous but that's what the law says
we can't individually decide what's
common sense when there's a law we have
to follow the law um no responsible
decision-making can be discussed or
addressed or activities around so no
more consequences for coming to school
without your homework um I just feel
there are so many problems in this state
so many things that you are all elected
to uh to address that are really
important and this bill is answering a
problem that doesn't exist and it's once
again undermining trust in public school
teachers who teach close to 90% of the
kids in this state thank you thank you
very much are there questions
representative belshire thank you Mr
chair thank you for your testimony uh
you just testified that there's no lack
of uh trust or faith um in teachers but
I'm looking at a Washington Post article
from 2022 the Stark drop in faith
demonstrating that only 28% of Americans
have faith in public schools are are you
saying that there's nothing behind that
number it's not happening well first of
all I didn't say there is no lack of
trust because I see lack of trust here
um but I'm saying that the parents I ran
into and I taught a thousand children
more than a thousand children none of
them indicated to me that they did not
trust their Public School teachers I
haven't read that article I have no idea
what the survey was I don't know if it
was valid or not so I can't address that
further questions from the committee not
seeing thank you very much thank you
have a good afternoon Aubrey fredman
sey uh Mr chair committee members Aubrey
Friedman from Bridgewater I speak in
support of this bill okay we are turning
our schools into medical centers what
happened to teaching basic academic
skills I mean if I would say if our
proficiency rates were 90% or better
then okay maybe we can work on some
other stuff they're not they're way low
and I'm in the Newfound district and our
Ela is up slightly but our math and
science are in the 30s and 40s so
there's a lot of work to be done we
should not have how this is a
distraction and by the way it is actual
classes that they are in so like a 1
hour period or 45 minutes or whatever
because I know the question came up it
is actually not working on math or
reading or whatever it is actual these
skills so it is taking they're only
there for 6 hours hours a day whatever
it is is taking away from academics on
the data collection I got a bunch of
backup here I'm sorry I didn't make 20
copies but please watch the video and
there's also a transcript in here and I
highlighted and we talk about data
collection and um I'm not saying that
the uh this Zoom meeting at the
department of uh education was with the
school counselors and what it is really
the way they talk about hiding things
from parents collecting the data we got
to get parental consent but you know uh
we how do you kind of skirt it by the
parents it is very revealing please
watch it or at least read the uh
transcript so when we talk about lack of
trust when I watched that it was a zoom
meeting I was it just infuriates me
about what's being sneaked in under the
radar here lastly the whole wscc whole
school whole child whole community this
whole seal thing was designed by the CDC
should we really trust them they're the
ones who messed up during the pandemic
so it's all designed from them and I
really question taking this uh whole uh
teaching stuff uh am I done yeah thank
you very much okay thank you are there
questions for Mr fredman you have copies
for do you have copies of that or do you
want to see I only have one copy but
please look through it and if you know
there's the the link to the vid it's
only like 30 minutes it's very telling
uh it's like kind of a private session
uh discussing data sharing and uh you
know how do you deal with this business
with a parental consent thank you if you
could submit that we incorporate into
Dunham
good I think we're still in morning good
morning chairperson lad and members of
the committee my name is Emma savini I'm
the children's Behavioral Health policy
coordinator at new Futures new Futures
is a nonpartisan nonprofit organization
that solves problems through policy
change I am here in strong uh opposition
to house full 1473 as written and the
amendment uh because it would put
students at risk of losing out in in
education that could support them
throughout their lives um traumatic
events in in a children's lifetime are
called adverse childhood experiences
commonly they're commonly referred to as
that um also known as Aces um and
experiencing even Four Aces throughout a
childhood puts someone at Great risk for
um long-standing um lifelong health and
mental Wellness uh conditions these
include uh anxiety depression uh
substance use disorder having protective
factors against those Aces is critical
in mitigating the the uh consequences to
experiencing those asay um social
emotional learning gives students the
tools to uh create those protective
factors against Aces and carry that
throughout their
lifetime in addition um social emotional
learning is um by and large a
partnership between schools and parents
so um for instance mtssb the program you
heard about from the sponsor and a
couple other folks um really emphasizes
the partnership between parents and the
schools and ensures that parents are not
only informed and given the chance to um
partake in the program but also extend
the learning at at home and it's a core
feature of of that
framework um finally parents and
caregivers are largely supportive of
social emotional learning um 86% of
respondents to the 603 bright future
survey which is given to families that
uh attend public schools in New
Hampshire um stated that they were in
agreement with the statement that social
emotional learning was important to
include in addition to academics and
schools um I'll wrap up there but I will
ask the committee to vote itl on thank
you very much are there
questions thank you thank you uh Bonnie
Breen
sorry for the committee we have enough
cards to go another 45 minutes
so you have to take a break to go to the
washroom or something go ahead and do
that hi I'm Bonnie dham I live in marac
New Hampshire and I'm here as a parent
of somebody who benefited from education
special education and social emotional
learning I'm stunned as to why someone
would want to discourage never mind
prohibit social and emotional learning
in schools isn't promoting schools in um
in Civic engagement a good thing don't
we want our kids to grow up to be good
citizens to have skills in the areas of
self-management relationship building
responsible decision making and
behaviors that that just makes sense um
this bill is particularly problematic
though for children with disabilities
who may have delays or deficits in areas
that include social emotional
development or social interaction skills
I have one of those people in my house
um and so I know how important it is for
those skills to be taught um and
sometimes it takes some real purposeful
teaching IEPs according to the federal
and state law must address both academic
and functional performance and
functional and performance includes
skills and behaviors in areas including
social skills and um and and emotional
development and once those areas have
been identified then there needs to be
an annual goal in there they need to be
progress needs to be measured um and
idea also emphasizes the use of positive
behavior interventions and supports for
particularly for children who need them
and that involves teaching both
self-management and behavioral skills I
don't know if it's the intent but this
Ida thank you very much are there
questions for Miss uh for Bonnie thank
not seeing thank you very much uh
deoy
we on this one right now hi my name is
Mary D I am a uh former teacher and a
retired mental health counselor for
children um I'm I here to oppose
1473 um we all have social emotional
health and from from birth to death and
as adults we know what we need to do if
we have problems if we need some
professional help we can get the help
that we need as children they're just
learning hopefully the foundations for
frustration or impulse to um control
friendship skills and how to how to make
friends um if they don't learn this then
those problems or feelings identified
with them intensify and multiply so as
they get older they have additional
problems we all know of people who
haven't had social emotional help in
their lives look at the drug overdoses
that we have which is on the rise of New
Hampshire look at the suicides committed
which is on the rise in New Hampshire
and look at how often do you hear of
mass Shooters who were loners who didn't
have friends who kept to themselves so
the root of all of this are feelings
that need to be identified when children
are young and they need to be worked
through because if they're not worked
through
these issues are the result of it so I'm
definitely opposed to this to me we
think we have we need more problems uh I
mean excuse me more programs that deal
health thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee thank
sperman followed
by
fillian oh it's right after good
afternoon good afternoon um I'm here
testifying um
about I'm not against teaching uh skills
but the problem is that the programs
that the schools that um that are
purchasing these seal programs are
crossing the line
um schools are replacing academics with
secl and this is the castle program
they're the parent company um they're
creating student
activists they're saying the school is
their safe space not the family they are
constantly giving out surveys and data
collection um when I was a child we all
heard about your permanent record oh
that's going to go on your permanent
record well now these kids are going to
have this permanent record and this data
is going to be out there forever and
they're never going to be able to escape
it so is that permanent record going to
be used in the future about getting a
job joining the Army um getting a loan
for something you did in third grade or
said in third grade um and I keep
hearing about parental consent is this
really informed consent that these
parents are getting they're getting told
that hey there's this program and you
know check out the website that we have
on this on the sa's uh website that just
gives you a very top layer of
information about anyl proam program we
don't know what are all the details and
the guts about every lesson plan unless
you file a right to know act um and then
i' also like to say that you know the
gentleman up here with um the dog and
doing the comfort and care and
everything I'm very concerned that that
child whether that child knew that the
information they wrote on that piece of
paper and threw away that information in
the waste basket was anyone else going
to access that
information and did the people did read
that information did they have the right
to read it and did they have the right
to know that information and if that
information happened to have said
something that there was abuse going on
who was going to contact the authorities
at that point and was what that child
wrote was that going to be inferred that
there was actual abuse going on your
time is
up further questions from the committee
Sarah
fillian followed by we're going to have
uh uh Michael Blair and Katherine 10
testimony good afternoon thank you for
the opportunity to address the committee
I'm Sarah fillian a former teacher for
nine years turned educational consultant
as a proud product of New Hampshire
schools I stand against hb1 1473 and
encourage you to join me our presence at
this meeting and maybe even going
through this meeting required us to
utilize essential skills
time management planning organizing
decision making and perhaps a dash of
motivation or
perseverance these seal skills vital in
adulthood must be nurtured from
childhood to empower individuals to
reach their potential and contribute
positively to
society in my 20 years of education
including teaching in both affluent and
economically disadvantaged schools I've
observed Seal's crucial role in enabling
all students to access education and
succeed when I was hired in the
Nashville School District I was warned
about the challenging nature of the
incoming fifth grade class one story
among many stands out about the power of
in nurturing their profound growth years
later a former student reached out to
share a pivotal moment from that year
with me the student was faced with
pressure to join his older brother's
gang despite the Temptation the
supportive environment of our classroom
convinced him otherwise he credited that
year as a time that he found genuine
friendship care from classmates and
teachers and a vision for his potential
Beyond gang life a robust body of
evidence highlights the positive effects
ofal on academics the research comes
from numerous sources including the
institute for Education sciences and the
National Institutes of Health all of
which have undergone rigorous review in
an increasingly interconnected and
diverse worldl skills are highly prized
by employers and vital for success in
all areas of life prohibiting through HB
1473 would stifle students personal
growth hamper academic achievement and
limit their capacity to thrive in an
everchanging world I urge you to oppose
hb1 1473 thank you for your time and
consideration that's right on the money
thank you very much I practiced a lot of
practice are there any questions from
the
committee thank you very much I'd like
to invite up uh Michael Blair and
Katherine 10 um both our students had to
get back to school
so and each one of you will have two
minutes and you can flip a coin ask who
wants to start oh we discussed it before
well I I'll start us off okay thank you
good afternoon my name is Michael Blair
I live in Manchester and I'm a senior at
Manchester Central High School I speak
today in opposition to House Bill
1473 and urge you to vote vote
no at Central I serve as class president
editor and chief of our school newspaper
and am a three sport vars athlete I also
serve on Governor sununu's youth
advisory Council on substance misuse and
prevention throughout high school I have
volunteered with the Jesse Lewis chws
love movement I speak today in my
individual capacity not on behalf of any
other person or group to share my
amazing experience with Choose Love
as a freshman working with the national
curriculum director for choose love I
and members of my hock High School
hockey team designed a curriculum that
our team presents to Young students at
at the Manchester Boys and Girls Club
each year our five session course called
Face Off Friends teaches the core values
of Courage forgiveness gratitude and
compassion in action using the game of
ice hockey as a
hook for me the most rewarding in part
of the Face Off Friends program is
seeing the excitement on the faces of
the young children at the Boys and Girls
Club I am most proud of that the
children look forward to Face Off
Friends each year I always enjoy
listening to the students telling me
stories of how they were compassionate
how they took a brave breath or showed a
growth mindset and even more seeing them
apply parts of this curriculum on the
playground with their
friends it is clear to me that what we
are teaching has a true beneficial
impact on their lives and positively
influences how they think act and live
seeing the real effect of this program
on a finite group of children I am
confident it will benefit Public Schools
where the program can reach and teach a
wider student body choose love has the
power to change lives for the better and
improve our community as a whole it
teaches skills we need for higher
learning and For the Working World your
time is up wrap it up quickly the Choose
Love program provides for all students
and encourages them to be the best
students and the best people they can be
once again I urge you to vote no on
House Bill
1473 thank you thank you very much are
there
questions
Katherine good afternoon my name is
Katherine ten uh I am from Manchester
and I'm a sophomore at Central High
School I'm a three- season athlete class
officer an editor of the school
newspaper drum major of the marching
band and counselor for the New Hampshire
legislative youth advisory Council I'm
here today to speak on behalf of myself
and oppose hb1
1473 I'm an ambassador for the Cho love
program a program that is focused on
building skills to prevent violence in
our community I teach the Face Off
Friends program modeled on the Choose
Love curriculum with members of the high
school's boys and girls hockey teams at
the Boys and Girls Club while helping
teach this curriculum I've noticed girls
who are unfamiliar with the sport come
together and make important connections
I have observed children who at first
seemed hesitant about the sport
consistently return each time we visited
and be excited about trying something
new and gaining confidence each session
chose love not only promotes important
qualities like courage and forgiveness
but it also creates an important
Community it encourages kids to try
something new and get out of their
comfort zone in a safe and encouraging
environment in 2023 the United States
Surgeon General released a report
raising alarm of the epidemic of
loneliness and mental health challenges
that young people confront he noted that
the loneliness and isolation increases
the risk of depression and anxiety for
children and teens it is especially
important to have programs that build
social connections and Foster Community
as a way to promote well-being for young
people choose love is the type of
program that creates a culture of
connection between people which is so
important to strong communities and
especially youth mental
health having experienced the choos love
program up close and working with the
children at the Manchester Boys and
Girls Club I believe Choose Love is the
type of program that would benefit
students students throughout the public
school system based on my experience I
hope that you will vote no on House Bill
1473 and allow this important program to
continue in public schools thank you for
allowing me to speak today thank you
very much other questions you students
are excellent representatives from
Manchester we want to tell say that
represent Cornell well I just want thank
you I just want to repeat that as a
graduate of central many years ago I
want to thank you um and your wonderful
examples of what our Manchester public
schools produce thank you and just
remember there's an excellent higher
education system down at UNH think about
it thank you so much thank you uh like
seiden good morning press on press the
button good morning chairman lad and
members of the House Education committee
my name is Fern seiden and I am the
director of student and staff Wellness
for the conquered School District I've
been an educator school counselor in New
Hampshire schools for over 20
years accessing social emotional
learning or seal in schools is a vital
part of getting a good education I think
we've seen some evidence of that today
seal provides a framework to
intentionally build skills such as
resilience perseverance Stress
Management and collaboration the
intentional integration ofal provides
young people with crucial life skills
necessary for academic success seal
skills and academics actually complement
each other rather than compete with each
other I oppose this bill because it
would prevent Educators from actually
applying the latest research on learning
and child development in order to
maximize the potential of all students
the bill also runs counter to the
Strategic plan of the conquered School
District which prioritizes the
development of the whole child and
recognizes that separating academic
achievement from social emotional skill
development would negatively impact our
ability for a successful education of
our
students I wanted to share a little bit
about what seal might look like I think
we've heard a lot of that but just a few
examples when a child puts their head
down on a desk and they're discouraged
the teacher has already worked with that
student in the classroom to develop
language around growth mindset and
strategies that they can use to then
Coach the child in that moment toward
re-engagement instead of losing the
child we're now re-engaging the child
for their education it is building a
toolbox of strategies to maintain stress
uh manage stress in a positive way by
the time a high school high achieving
high school student is struggling to
manage a strenuous workload they have
spent spent years learning about Stress
Management a protective factor that
supports mental
Wellness in summary research in the
field of scci in the science of human
development and learning your time is up
thank you well I wanted to one more
thing is that the castle framework I
want to clarify it is a framework it
does not provide a social emotional
learning curriculum it's a framework
that you can use to develop a social
emotional learning curriculum with so I
just wanted to clar ify that because
I've heard that mentioned several times
and it does not require the collection
of data um on and especially personal
data on students thank you for the
clarification uh representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony um regarding the
Choose Love movement
inal um in June of 2023 the uh State
Department of Education tweeted out an
image from the Choose Love movement
titled June self self care advertising
ways people can help care for themselves
now most of the stuff doesn't raise an
eyebrow except one thing on here it says
it says appreciate your assets and
there's a little emoji of a peach now
for background on this the peach Emoji
has been banned in a lot of social media
because it's often used to symbolize
genitalia can you speak to what exactly
this is trying to tell children to do
and has how it has to do with social
emotional
learning I have no idea about what the
peach represents but I do know that we
talk a lot about developing student
assets um and that when we have these
skills they become assets for us to in
order to thrive in the in school and
Beyond in the workplace so I'm sorry I
don't know that reference further
questions from the committee not see any
hands thank you very much thank you uh
invite Patricia Tilly DHHS and followed
SBA
good morning committee for the record my
name is Patricia Tilly I am an associate
commissioner with the Department of
Health and Human Services I am also
proudly uh happen to be a former middle
school teacher in a former life I'm
representing the Department of Health
and Human Services opposition to hp1
1473 it is Impractical and has wide
reaching and undeterminable effects that
you have heard for the past few hours we
have only now seen the amendment as you
have but the original language as
introduced would prohibit any program
that even sniffs of Social and emotional
language and it would eliminate
opportunities for surveys such as the
yrbs I want to begin by agreeing
wholeheartedly with the sponsor and
others in this room that the with the
fundamental belief that social and
emotional learning starts at home
parents and caregivers play the most
important and primary role in teaching
and modeling healthy Social Development
and relationships but as you have heard
here today from students to teachers all
of us have a part to play there can
never be too many trusted and skilled
adults in a child's life to help
navigate complex emotions that we can
prevent the outcomes of emotional
physical and sexual abuse and violence
as well as poor academic performance due
to the inability to effectively
communicate in groups and peer
relationships there are hundreds of
studies that support this notion that is
why the Department of Health and Human
Services supports programs in schools
that develop Partnerships with amilies
and schools uh based on Mutual trust
understanding and civility across
differences none of these programs
reduce the powerful role of caregivers
rather they enhance the Notions of
kindness respect and empathy that is
learned at home but with 44% of New
Hampshire High School students reporting
feeling sad or hopeless in the past year
among girls alone that bumps up close to
60% and the epidemic of loneliness that
you've heard about already there is no
doubt that student wellness impacts
academic import um performance and
academic environments sadly underscoring
this data we are faced with the fact
that suicide is the leading cause of
death among 10 to 23 year olds in New
Hampshire we believe that even with the
amendment hb1 1473 puts forward the
following Department funded programs are
at risk New Hampshire student assistant
programs they are school-based programs
funded by the department in more than 70
communities to provide support to middle
and high school students struggling with
individual family and peer challenges
thank you your your time is up great
thank you I will just sum by saying we
have written testimony that we will pass
around there are a number of programs
that would all be defunded even with
this amendment the language is
Impractical thank you questions from for
DHHS yes represent belshire thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here could you
speak uh please speak to the propriety
of an executive agency taking a position
on a bill and how that is not a conf ICT
of Interest or ethics violation sure
there is State Statute that allows that
I can't think of the number off the top
of my head we must um identify ourselves
as members of the executive agency and
we have the authority and statute to to
take a position thank you thank
you yeah further questions from the
committee thank you very much Becky
Wilson followed by
John
IND John I don't know if I got your last
name got it okay uh thank you for
hearing my testimony today for the
record Becky Wilson I'm the director of
governmental relations for the New
Hampshire school boards Association uh I
will send in extensive written testimony
referencing our resolutions which guide
our opposition to this bill however
given the extensive testimony you've
already heard I would like to just
highlight some of the current
initiatives programs and statutes and
rules many of which have been put into
practice directly as a result of by
partisan legislation that has come out
of this committee which we feel would no
longer be available if this bill or the
amendment were to pass um you've heard
many of them already I will try to read
them as quickly as I can uh
mtssb the definition of bullying
obligations to address bullying bully
investigation cyber bullying granting or
considering a manifested hardship for
any reason that's somehow related to a
child's feelings relationships emotions
social situations uh Charter Schools
whose mission is built on serving
students who are at risk um who are who
exhibit a need for social emotional
support family engagement programs
surveys um and indicator data that's on
the 603 survey that comes out of the
Department of Ed uh Suicide Prevention
listing The Suicide Prevention Hotline
and potentially the Eating Disorders
hotline on the back of student IDs
Federal safe grants stronger connections
grants which over the past several years
have allowed uh districts to better
address uh pandemic learning loss and
support for students and families across
communities work faced soft skills
training as part of CTE programs which
are requested by employers for students
who are coming out of CTE graduation
Alliance which is a mentoring program
out of the department the suspension and
expulsion rules best buddies Unified
sports youth Mental Health First Aid uh
the partnership with Justice brri and
and Dartmouth Health one trusted adult
trauma informed care and all of the
repeting uh Federal idea and state
issues around special education uh as
well as being able to place a student at
an out of District placement who does
not comply with this law because the Lea
is responsible for ensuring that
District placements comply with New
Hampshire law uh hiring social workers
adjustment counselors uh Juvenile
Justice programs diversion and
restorative practice and I'm happy to
take any questions thank you any
questions thank you much Becky thank you
David Trumble f
darl he had to go he's gone John yeah
John you're up after
good good thank you Mr chairman and
committee members I'll keep it brief
you've heard all of tremendous evidence
on the effectiveness of SEO the one
argument that seems to be coming back is
does it conflict with academic studies
because you're using time that could be
spent there so a little research on that
there's a study done reported in child
development uh and it's a review of
97,000 students from 82 schools who took
place in Seal programs the study showed
that three and a half years after their
last seal inv involvement students fared
marketly better academically than their
peers in control grp groups by an
average of 13 percentile points based on
eight studies that measured academics so
if you're worried about the performance
scores and schools this just tells you
and you heard the reason child comes in
they're not set to start work for the
day the day is a mess for them you do
some work to help them get centered the
child has a productive day after seal
your scores for as a school go up 13
percentage points that would be huge we
certainly shouldn't fight against that
it also said that it reduces drug use
and emotional distress another study
from Columbia University this one was in
the Journal of benefit cost
analysis uh says that seal programs
return $11 for every dollar invested
this report from Columbia University
details a benefit cost analysis
evaluating six seal intervention
programs that shows an average return on
investment of $11 for every dollar spent
so it not only increases academic scores
it saves the schools money it's a
productive program how does it do this
it reduces child aggression substance
abuse delinquency and violence students
don't end up missing school if they feel
like school is a safe place to be if
students aren't there how are they going
to get academic progress it also lowers
levels of depression and anxiety it
increases grades it increases attendance
and performance in core academic
subjects that question was asked half a
dozen times so I think hopefully these
will answer that thank you Mr chair
thank you very much other questions from
Mr Trimble
thank you very much you're
welcome
John Al bendero I guess it is Will
Follow he's
gone then be Tera
font following thank welcome John thank
you how do you say your last name uh
udas okay I gu best pronounced all the
time that's okay um I'm a licensed
independent clinical social worker and a
master's license alcohol drug counselor
and I won't repeat too many of the
points I already made but um up here as
a citizen right now because I saw the
legislative alert about this bill and it
struck a chord because I've been asked
in this room before and in other public
forums when I was serving on different
boards the providers
Association um and nasw about what's the
best prevention for addiction especially
which is something that I'm an expert on
I taught classes at UNH for it um and I
always say it's teaching kids between
the the age of like five and 12 how to
identify their emotions ground
themselves calm themselves down ask for
what they need in a more productive way
um and that's what my understanding of
social emotional learning is um if there
are other studies and data and questions
that could ask like perhaps the
amendment putting some limits on that
could help a little bit but removing
this from curriculum is sort of
impossible and I don't know why you
would want to do it because it would
just cause way more problems than it
solves um and to answer the question
that representative Bel had asked
earlier about forgiveness and how that
activity helps someone um there's a lot
of research that connects forgiveness to
mental health but the bottom line is
it's kind of Common Sense Neuroscience
that if someone is distracted and
escalated about um an emotional issue
then they're not going to be able to
attend to any academic learning so um
that's what we need to teach kids so
that they can be successful academically
and socially and prevent drug overdose
and prevent addiction and prevent them
from ending up in programs like the one
that I operate in the Sea Coast which is
for adults with addiction and mental
health problems so um I think everything
else has been touched on but I just like
I said I'm not a part of any of those
boards anymore but when I saw this
legislation being proposed I felt like I
needed to explain that that's that's how
you prevent those problems from
happening later in life so thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
are there questions from the committee
mlan this is choose love hello thank you
very much for having me here my name is
Tara F I am a resident of Newberry New
Hampshire I'm not here as an educator or
a therapist working with children I'm
here as a parent I actually work in
technology and I have to say that I'm so
Greatful to have seen so many parent
excuse me so many teachers and so many
academics here in support of the kids um
I became involved in uh the Choose Love
program after the Uval school shooting I
had reached out and started working with
Shannon and Scarlet Lewis um I just want
to provide clarification on a couple of
things if I May um excuse me I have to
breathe the Choose Love movement does
not do any data collection of the
children the Choose Love movement does
ask Educators if they want to provide
feedback as people would with any
program nor do they require money so you
can opt into other programs with in
choose love but you do not have to pay
anything UPF front so how I became
involved in choose love with ubaldi
school shooting is I had employed choose
love with Recycled Percussion into an
anti-bullying event in Newport New
Hampshire and someone here asked that
was in April of last year someone in
here asked how have you seen this move
forward so coincidentally or
fortuitously last week I met a girl who
was from Newport New Hampshire who told
me that her mother taught in the school
system and I said oh I had helped
facilitate an event there did you buy
any chance did your mom say anything and
she said nope my mom didn't say anything
but my younger brother who is in eighth
grade said the woman that spoke there
and she said is her name Scarlet I said
yes it is and she said that story
resonated with him and he has made it a
point to be kind and
courageous and considerate and
compassionate to the children in his
school and to look for that little boy a
little girl who may not seem like
everybody else but perhaps needs a
little compassion that was back in April
of 2023 your time is up and it still
resonates today that's all thank you
thank you very much other questions from
the committee thank you thanks Mark mlan
followed by Ryan
agualina Mark's not
here is Ryan
here
Jean
you hello I just want to start off by
saying wow those kids said it all um I
am a third grade teacher and I have been
teaching in Nashua for 24 years years
and I absolutely oppose this bill and it
is with passion I teach at uh seal um
the National School District uses the
Choose Love program and for those of you
who are not familiar with that um Choose
Love was created by Scarlet Lewis when
so sadly her child was shot and killed
in the Sandy Hook shooting and she was
devastated as any parent as any person
would be and she came back from home and
on the chalkboard her child Jesse had
written in his first grade writing uh a
few words courage
forgiveness and it really resonated with
her and she felt so compelled to it just
sort of came to her this is her life's
meaning uh to create the Choose Love
program and for those of you who are not
familiar with Choose Love it repres it's
a very simple formula it represents
courage gratitude forgiveness
compassion um and also uh most of you
probably know that Governor Seno has
endorsed this amazing program in New
Hampshire and he actually has appointed
the program manager who works in his
office um and I that really resonates
with me um I use choose love in my
classroom every day um we start our day
with our our morning meeting and I say
good morning to every one of my students
I look in their eyes and I say what are
you grateful for today and I express my
gratefulness it might be as simple as I
was able to see the sunrise or something
like that and scientific research shows
that by expressing gratitude and this is
just a fraction of this amazing program
it reduces anxiety and it just helps
people be healthier and feel better I
also want to express that when my all
the tools like that little girl Express
um when we take assessments some
children are very anxious um and we take
a breath and we calm our bodies so um I
urge you to please o oppose this bill um
thank you very much for your time thank
you very much are there any questions
from the committee on seeing thank you
very much terara Spencer followed by
Ariel
Smith
thank good afternoon my name is Tera
Spencer I'm a school psychologist at
Abbott Downing school I have been a
school psychologist for the conquered
School District since the fall of 200
and three it's a little
while I have been teaching a have been
teaching teaching social emotional
learning class to kindergarteners and
first graders as a special for the past
3 years I am also here as a parent of a
first grader and a fifth grader I could
go into the research citing statistics
showing that social emotional learning
improves School attendance academic
performance graduation rates Etc I could
talk about how when students are
experiencing big feelings they're not
available for
instruction um other people have hit on
those topics what I want to talk to you
today about is what does this look like
in schools so you saw Cordelia who
reported on the emotional ABCs that is
one of the programs we're doing in
addition to choose
love this looks every day like students
who are coming up to me telling me they
were able to use their deep breathing
they use their five senses to ground
their bodies so that they could retry
that math
problem it looks like kids on the
playground using their words instead of
handson to solve who gets to be goalie
during soccer at
recess this looks like students
vocabulary for feelings growing from
just saying they're upset to being able
disappointed I've had students come into
my office who initially were not able to
name any ing strategies that they had to
calm big feelings now when I ask kids
what's in your toolbox what strategies
do you have to deal with these big
feelings students are at least able to
name three and that's not just name
skills that they have learned this is
name naming skills that they actually
can use successfully thank you for your
time today thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee
represent
Damon thank you could you just give us a
couple of examples of the strategies
sure um Cordelia talked about the five
finger breathing we do so many different
breathing strategies hot cocoa breathing
um we do the Choose Love Brave breath um
with the younger kids we might do bird
breathing um where we incorporate the
body into that um we also
do the five senses where we will think
about okay what are five things I see
four things I hear um um three things I
feel you know two things I or one thing
I can taste you know we go through all
the senses what can you think of for
those things to help ground kids there's
also we may kind of um shake out some of
the feelings um we may do mindful
activities like rainbow scavenger hunt
that's a big one at our school where
kids can sit in their seat and they look
for something every color of the rainbow
so that doesn't require them to get up
out of their seat they can sit in their
seat they can find something every color
it helps calm their bodies and then
they're ready to work we talk about
taking pit stops where kids May
recognize they need a drink of water
they may need to take a walk to the
bathroom um none of this takes away from
their time um and when you think about
if they're grounded then they're
available for instruction and that's not
taking away time thank you very much
representative Miler thank you Mr chair
and thank you for being here and thank
you for the work you do with your
students uh as a result of the program
that you implemented there in the last
three years have you seen uh a decrease
in the discipline problems that you have
in school we have I don't have the
statistics on me but we
have and when we do have kids that are
having what we call bumps um they're
able to turn those bumps around more
quickly so what could have been an
episode where a kid was off for an hour
we can now let them self- regulate maybe
co-regulate with them where we sit down
we do some deep breathing and they
breathe with us and they're able to turn
it around so much quicker within a
matter of a few minutes thank you thank
you very much are there further
questions thank you very much my wife
oftentimes tell me Rick stand up tall
and take a deep breath yeah yeah yeah
good for her Ariel Smith followed by
Megan
Phillips
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Ariel Taylor Smith and I am
the senior director of policy and action
at the National Parents Union I am here
today to respectfully oppose HB 1473 as
originally introduced the National
Parents Union runs the longest running
National parent poll in the country and
overwhelmingly over the last 38 polls we
have heard that parents are concerned
about their kids mental health 89% of
parents in our latest poll said that
policy makers should be focused on
improving student mental health also
according to our polling 81% of parents
say that public schools should teach
about and discuss Concepts like kindness
empathy cooperation and collaboration
82% of parents oppose curriculum bands
according to the National survey on drug
use and health in teens 12- 17 there has
been 145% increase since 2010 in teen
girls and 161% increase in teen boys who
were reporting major depression last
year in girls ages 10 through 14 since
2010 there's been 188% increase in
Hospital admissions for non-fatal self
harm we are seeing a major and deeply
concerning increase in suicide self harm
anxiety and depression among our kids
now is not the time to be banning the
teaching of resiliency and empathy I
also want to note a concerning component
in the original bill which is a ban on
Civic engagement in our rapidly evolving
Society Foster ing act active
citizenship is crucial Banning Civic
engagement for New Hampshire students
would deny our students the chance to
develop into informed responsible and
engaged members of our community civic
participation instills values of empathy
critical thinking and a sense of
responsibility toward the greater good
moreover social emotional learning plays
a critical role in shaping well-rounded
individuals and Studies have shown that
it results in academic gains seal plays
an important role in supporting student
academics and it can posit positively
contribute to indicators of academic
achievement including School climate a
sense of belonging and strong student
teacher relationships it equip students
with the emotional intelligence needed
to navigate life's
challenges um I urge you to reconsider
the potential consequences of banning
these essential components of Education
please uh let us continue to empower our
students with the skills and the
knowledge they need to contribute
meaningful to our Democratic Society
thank you thank you questions from the
committee thank you very much for coming
and hanging in there so long thank you
Phillips hi
folks so I'm Megan Phillips and I am a
clinical psychologist by training and I
uh work at the behavioral health
Improvement Institute at Keane State
College uh as a principal investigator
lead evaluator and direct the New
Hampshire mtssb technical assistance
center in partnership with the
Department of of Education in the state
I am here as a neutral party um I like
to come and keep an eye out for
inaccuracies in the testimony and then
um luckily end a blast on the docket so
I can try to address just a few of those
very very
quickly um I do have some written
testimony that comes from our technical
assistance center which summarizes the
literature and the evidence behind
social emotional learning its
integration into Frameworks such as
mtssb and I just would highly encourage
the committee to take a look at it
there's been a lot of um evidence talked
about here and I want you to have the
actual literature in your hands or
citations for the actual literature so
you can make informed decisions that are
based on
reality couple of very quick
clarifications based on what I heard
today that I think are important one is
I think we're having a confusion and a
confabulation between social emotional
learning curricula and social emotional
and behavioral screening social
emotional curricula or curriculum their
curricula they're taught like any other
subject matter and often integrated into
the academic curriculum which is
actually the most effective way the
literature um shows to do that what it
isn't is screening or surveys certainly
schools can make a decision to have an
adjunct survey or data collection tool
but it's not an inherent part of
curriculum a social emotional learning
curriculum um I want to clarify that
terms like mental health treatment um
and assessment I would caution folks
about using those terms in this context
assessment is a as a psychologist is a
process of psychological um assessment
using multiple tools by a qualified
individual and that is not a part of
social emotional learning curricula in
schools if teachers are asked to
complete a survey or a rating scale to
um provide information on student
behavior and how students are doing um
those are called screenings and they are
based on observation not on
interpretation that would be considered
part of an assessment process because
teachers are not qualified to do that
and they're not asked to do that so just
be careful when you hear those terms
mental health
assessment those are above and beyond
and I just want folks to be careful
about that thank you very much your your
time is up and yes we are familiar with
mtssb yes I know I have talked to you
about it before thank you yes are there
any other cards because we are done
everything that's up here on the pink
card right
now yes yes could I could I have two
minutes speak I did not fill out a card
I didn't anticipate speaking today you
can fill out a card but you can't speak
without the card okay I'll do that thank
you and you will be the last person
speaking thank
card
yeah just let Marg know you're head it
different this is
my
exactly you can fill that card out after
you've spoken we're trying to move on
here
okay
grie Phillips Bristol New Hampshire
thank you for the opportunity uh what
the reason I'm motivated to speak is
because with all the conversation I've
heard today many of us agree with 95%
plus of all these concerns over good
counseling for children as an employer I
had people work with me who had
disabilities and I always accommodated
that as an employer and got good
successful results with them those are
my qualifications as I speak I think the
one key issue that's not adequately been
addressed is this it because cell does
implement a broad brush approach the on
problem the problem lies in the areas of
the fact that the tentacles of cell are
in everything that opens a door for
teachers counselors and others to go
ahead and indoctrinate children and and
and in uh re uh values that may be
contrary to those of the parent um when
it comes to addressing the emotional
social needs of students I think the
best approach and a lot of us feel this
way is to go ahead and have teacher and
counselor trainings in the these two
areas disability
detection that uh hinders effective
learning so that accommodation can be
made through IEPs and number two
detection of emotional disturbances that
would be severe enough to to prevent
successful learning this broad brush
brush approach opens the door for
opportunities of indoctrinations that
usurp the rights of
parents you can go ahead and cite how it
is that cell programs have improved
academic learning but any peer review
would go ahead and say well wait just a
minute here you're talking about
Improvement of Education among a limited
specialized population who are needy and
the needs of that population should not
in any way effective learning
across the board specialized counseling
after the your time is up thank you very
much thank you very much other questions
from the committee not seeing any uh we
you for the
committee we do have a number of bills
and we're falling behind I I believe
what we can do here is that there are
some folks that came for 1625 they're
waiting in the hallway I'm going to go
ahead and open that up and take
testimony if but if there are those
right here that's a bill that just makes
you know a very simple change here in
the bill so we'll hear that one and then
we're going to take a break but if you
want to take your break now go ahead
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
1625 are you wanting to introduce that
yeah
you whatever you want to do with it I
cabinet
okay we're going to go ahead and open up
1625 the it's relative to school health
services representa cordelli would you
please introduce the bill uh thank you
Mr chairman uh for the record uh Glenn
cordelli representing Tuftonboro
wolfboro and oopy in the beautiful Lakes
Region and I would like to introduce
House Bill
1625 uh that makes a simple change um
related to um the certification or
nurses for thank you are there any
questions thank you very much uh Sean
par he had to
leave James D
Duran
Durkin so he's
going and we're going to leave the
discussion to two minutes
each thank you chairman lad members of
the committee uh for the record Jim
Durkin from ASI Council 93 here to
express our support for House Bill
1625 legislation aimed at helping school
districts continue to address the
problem of filling a high number of
vacant school nurse positions in our
Public Schools we made great progress in
addressing this shortage in the previous
legisl uh legislative session through
the passage of Senate Bill 215 which
reduce the minimum education
requirements for a school nurse from a
4-year degree to a 2-year degree that
legislation which enjoyed strong
bipartisan support was signed into law
by governor sonunu and has helped cities
like Manchester attract new applicants
to these positions but a shortage still
exists we believe this bill would build
on the progress achieved in the previous
session by removing yet another barrier
for district seeking to attract
qualified nurses quite simply the bill
removes the requirement for School
nurses to be certified IED by the
department of Ved and transfer is the
responsibility where we and sponsors of
this legislation believe it belongs with
the State Board of Nursing indeed the uh
Board of Education also agreed in fact
that the hearing on the aformentioned uh
Bill nearly one year ago to the day uh
the chairman of the State Board of Ed
stated and I'm I'm paraphrasing here but
stated that the board would prefer to
leave the responsibility of
certification to the board of nursing uh
one of our as me School nurses working
in Manchester Mr Patricia rangin has
submitted written testimony which talks
about this in much greater detail I have
printed copies for the committee uh so I
won't elaborate any further uh as she
covers this point quite well I'll just
close with one key Point Mr chairman a
number of vacancies still exist in our
schools and now perhaps more than ever
we need our school staffed with
qualified nurses the needs of our
children and teens in our high schools
are drastically different than the days
when I and probably a lot of p uh people
on this committee uh were students uh
unfortunately with the problems of
things like childhood obesity alone kids
and teens are dealing with more complex
health issues such as diabetes high
blood pressure or even food allergies
many are taking medication on a daily
basis time is up thank you is that all
written testimony that you have we could
put that right into the record and get
uh yes i' I I've got a couple of copies
here for you Mr German um again this is
just build on progress and we appreciate
the uh the the legislation very much
thank you thank you very much I'm sorry
I have I do my best to answer questions
if the committee has any questions yes
represent Tanner um I somehow I thanks
for taking my question I missed do you
represent a school district and does
that school district have nurses that
are certified through this State
Department of Education yes uh we've got
about 4,000 uh members here in New
Hampshire but one of our biggest locals
is in Manchester where there's uh right
now I think there's 26 positions in
Manchester um they were able to fill
with that legislation I mentioned
earlier they were able to fill three of
them last year but those were for
retiring nurses so we're essentially
just Treading Water there uh there's
currently nine vacant positions in
Manchester those are staffed by a
revolving pool of contract nurses uh
from an agency which is is quite
expensive um and also you know you have
the problem where
they don't know the kids they don't get
a chance to know the kids like people
who are permanently stationed in the
school know their individual needs their
their medical needs things like that so
just to qualify you're a union yes
ma'am which Union do you represent uh
American Federation of state county and
Municipal Employees thank you thank you
further questions yes representative
Ford thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question what purpose does the
certification by the depart I mean what
does the Department of Education ask of
a nurse that wouldn't have been asked by
a nursing organization uh it's it's a
very good question uh I'm not quite sure
I do know that like any kind of uh
process it is cumbersome they go through
a background check just like they the a
lot of the same things that are done by
the the Board of Nursing to certify well
we think this would be particularly
helpful is right now you've got this
shortage of of of nursing so a lot of a
lot of school districts are kind of
stealing from each other for lack of a
better term because you've got to have
that that department of Ed
certification uh in order to go into a
school district what this would do would
be to allow people allow districts to
hire people directly from the private
sector they could start right away and
not have to begin the certification
process uh through the department thank
you for committee not seeing thank you
Association thank you chairman mad
committee my name is Pam Denley um I'm a
school nurse and um I teach in the
school of nursing Masters program at um
elm's college and I live in Manchester
the nurse the New Hampshire Nurses
Association supports our affiliate the
New Hampshire school nurse Association
in opposing HB 1625 relevant to school
nurse certification I did just want to
clarify that there's a difference
between certification and lure So
currently the nurses are licensed by the
Board of Nursing and certified by the
Department of Education um as nurses
were disappointed at the attempt to
further discredit School nurses the
purpose of certification is to improve
the nurses ability to provide the best
patient care to our schoolage children
and to demonst at the commitment they
have to the specialty nursing practice
School nurses are often the only health
professional in the school and practice
autonomously in that role as you aware
children in our schools have
increasingly complex medical needs and
mental health issues requiring the nurse
to assess diagnose and treat as many as
55 children in a single day in my own
journey to be a school nurse I've had to
often
uh substantiate why I want to be school
nurse based on my education and I think
that um what the certification process
does is allow our employers to know that
they have quality nurses in their
schools um it's one of the most
challenging things I've ever done in my
career to be a school nurse um many of
my students I taught at UNH for 20 years
I had all my students rotate through
School nurses and they would all come
back and say to me I've never had such a
uh respect for the quality and the and
the skill of a school nurse so um I
think that it's really important to
understand what certification
demonstrates and that's the ability for
nurses to provide excellent and
experienced clinical Care thank you are
there questions yes representative
pedell thank you and thank you for
taking my question I I understand what
you're saying about nurses you know
being certified and it's important to be
educated and how to care for children in
the school is there a separate
professional certification that you a
nurse
could there's there's a national
certification so this is actually a
state certification so many of our I I
work in Manchester many of our
Manchester nurses are actually
nationally School certified so that's a
really uous process and um it would be
the most respected certification for our
profession but it's at at this time a
lot of people find it really a barrier
so this this school nurse certification
that we're talking about was the doe you
have to have years of experience and you
have to have a certain amount of
continuing education specific to working
in a school environment so that's why
it's really valuable to New
Hampshire representative Tanner and then
representative M thank you thank you for
taking my question um I believe before
we actually had a a school nurse
specialist at the Department of
Education yeah um do you know if that
position has ever been filled it's never
been filled represent Miler thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here I this is
not a new issue for this committee no uh
so we've got a lot of new people on this
committee could you please specifically
talk about the difference of
lure versus
certification and what would be the
impact of if this particular piece of
legislation were to become law right so
uh a nurse of graduate from a a nursing
school an accredited nursing school so
they would either receive their
associate degree or or their bachelor's
degree then we take What's called the
enlex exam which is a it's the um
National exam and you become a
registered nurse so what this committee
did last year was to say what the
certification requirement used to be you
had to have you had to have a BSN to be
a school nurse and then then be
certified what this committee did last
year was to say you could start as an
associate degree nurse which is a 2-year
degree but had to be working towards
your bachelor's degree towards
certification within 6 years so that's
the that's the lure so any anybody who
calls thems a registered nurse has a
license through the National Council of
State Boards of Nursing in in this bill
the certification for a school nurse is
um continuing education specific to
school nursing and um working towards
your bachelor's degree so you have to
have your what this what this body did
last year was to say that within 6 years
you have to have your bachelor's degree
so you essentially have six years to
work towards certification and this bill
would disallow that then right so what
this bill so so the confusion I think is
to say well it's already in the board of
nursing which it's not the board of
nursing licenses all nursing they
certify some they certify nurse
Educators they certify Advanced
registered nurse practitioners they
certify nurse anesthetist this bill or
this certification is through the
Department of Education and specific
spefically because nurses School nurses
work in schools and they have to have a
certain amount of Education around
working in a school like what is a 504
plan what is an IEP so that's sort of
specialty education that you have to be
successful in your role thank you very
much further questions from the
Wells
thank you Mr chairman um and committee
members it's nice to be here um my name
is Nancy Wells I am uh the Lea for the
New Hampshire school Nurses Association
and I am the former um school nurse
coordinator with the Department of
Education that position is not is that
is not filled at the moment I'm here to
object to House Bill
1625 and I remain committed to the
necessity and the Integrity of the
school nurse certification that we have
just to give you a quick um picture of
why we came up with certification the
Department of Education previously had
required certification of School nurses
with our RSA 229 since 2016 we've met
several times and we've added extra time
for people to get the necessary
education or training that to make it so
that they would meet the qualifications
for certification as a quality and
professional school nurse in the past
School administrators and the Educators
and parents had made complaints to the
doe about issues with uh regarding
School nurses not following School
protocols not buying into the school
framework and certainly not providing
basic nursing care that was very
upsetting to a lot of us um the former
Commissioner of Education met with
myself and several of the New Hampshire
school nurse
leaders and we identified the need for
more Education and Training for a nurse
to function in the specialty practice of
nursing school nursing
we work with the Department of Ed and
the surrounding states um who also
require state certification as well as
the National Association of School
nurses to identify those specific areas
needed for practice and that became the
basis of what we require for
certification um I don't have to tell
you how complicated our Pro our practice
is right now with um certainly students
with anaphylaxis with asthma esthesia
disorders those students who are
homeless students who don't speak
English as their primary language
anguage um as well as the multiple
physical conditions that now come to
school that we take care of in within
the school
setting
um it's we have gone beyond your two two
minutes can I just do two one second
okay it's school nurse who Bridges the
Two Worlds of healthc care and education
the nurse must be able to speak the
language of Education as well as
integrate the students Health needs into
the education mayor and certification
provides the guarantee that every
professional working in the school has
the ability to provide quality
Professional Services and that's what
our school nurse certification does
thank you very much represent Damon
thank you thank you for being here and
taking my
question would you know if a district is
using contract nurses because they have
not yet been able to fill all their
positions are those contract nurses
certified through Department of Ed I
don't think so um but I will tell you
that there's uh across the state there's
one open position in school Nur nursing
right
now that's different information than we
heard a few minutes ago I
know F the question represent M thank
you for being here could you clarify I
mean isn't a nurse a nurse I what what
what what what's the certification
needed to be a school nurse rather than
a regular nurse I think when we we talk
about school nursing a school nurse must
be able to work as an inter
interdisciplinary team we need to know
what the school psychologists do what
the social workers do what the teachers
do we need to U make sure that we can
understand um what the goals of being in
school are um that's different than what
I would do as a as a nurse uh for my
patient in the hospital um because there
I can control what is happening with
them what kind of medications I can give
them but in a school we really have to B
answer to the Board of Pharmacy to U the
American Medical Association the New
Hampshire Medical Society we have to do
um what the education goals are so it's
a really a lot more of pulling together
a lot more resources to become um make
sure that that student can come to
school and be safe and participate in
the school world thank you represent
Tanner thank you I'm I'm just a little
bit
confused because we just had somebody
from the um abma labor union who said
that in Manchester uh they were having a
great deal of difficulty getting uh
nurses for the schools and yet you said
that there's only one open position
could you clarify how that meshes
together I can't answer for Manchester I
do know that there's a nurse in every
school in Manchester um and they fill
them with with agency nurses I don't
have the answer as to why uh Manchester
is not fulfilling with School nurses
regular School nurses that are certified
I don't have an answer for that we did
have that information provided to us
when this round went around previously
in another year um represent
P thank you so just to clarify the board
of education has a position to certify
School nurses and was that you I was
school nurse coordinator I I did more
than just provide information for
certification I was a person who sort of
integrated all of those laws that come
together um I went around and answered
parents questions and helped nurses with
their particular challenges in their in
their
practice follow up so you weren't
actually certifying the School nurses
this is the Department of Education has
a certification program it's a different
department than what she was doing
certification is over here and she was
that's what I was trying to clarify
thank you yeah no talking about Steve
applebe yes yes okay further questions
from the committee see thank you very
Compton good after thank you chair
representative lad um okay my name is
Linda Compton and I'm a lifelong
resident of New Hampshire and I have
been a registered nurse for over 43
years
and the last 30 years have been in the
educational
setting um I got my associate degree and
then I went on to get my bachelor's
degree and they were both in the um in
New Hampshire I went to nhti and I went
to the university and then I went on to
get my masters in Community Health
Administration and wellness
promotion I just retired in June of 2023
however I still provide continuing
education to School nurses in New
Hampshire along with I am continuing to
serve and I've been on for quite a while
um on the New Hampshire board of nursing
practice and education committee I have
also been a past board member of the
Board of
Nursing um there are many School nurses
that have fulfilled the BSN requirement
for certification and others that are
currently working towards their
Bachelors there are different levels of
the New Hampshire uh Department of aded
certification school nurse one 2 and
three based on what their education is
coming into the profession of school
nursing um I have had a chance to talk
to some of the school nurses that uh
have gone on from their ADN to get their
Bachelors since the certification has
been in place and they said now they see
the why School nurses need to have the
bachelors in the
certification um and I feel sometimes
you don't know what you don't know you
don't see the blind spots until you
actually been involved with the
process um the the critical thinking
decision-making informatics data
analysis research analysis and knowledge
gained on Community Health and research
principles were some of the professional
growths that occurred during this
process and they say that it they felt
that it has enhanced their nursing uh
profession to the students of uh in the
school in New
Hampshire school nursing is a unique
nursing specialty School nurses are
community public health professionals to
provide services in the educational
setting the laws and rules uh by the
Department of Education are very much
part of what the School nurses need to
abide by along with nursing laws rules
Pharmacy laws dhh laws other laws but
they are part of the educational setting
your time is up
oh can I just say one more closing B
yeah one more thing if that's written
also we'll take that written testim oh
okay all right yeah you can have the
written testimony I'm just is going to
say that I am you know uh opposed to the
the um
1625 um bill and I think the
certification still needs to stand for
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee
represent
Damon two straightforward questions
thank you for being here can you tell us
what the cost of certification is and
could you also give us any information
about whether other states have a
similar certification requirement it is
is I do believe still at $75 for the
three-year
certification and there are other states
I mean I don't have them off the top of
my head but I know like say in Rhode
Island they are school nurse teachers
along with they do this whole teacher
certification along with being the
registered nurse and
Massachusetts has last I knew they were
at the Master's level for school I mean
School nursing is very independent very
much you have to be able to be a leader
in the field of nursing to really
be things that need to happen within
today's um Healthcare and school the
education set thank you very much
reminder to the committee here that when
we certify through the department we're
also having to work for through the
department of safety there is a fee for
certification which the department
charges and then on top of that you have
safety as well so it is over $100 total
comes out closer we found little around
140 some odd the other day with another
category uh further questions from the
committee thank you very much okay
you're welcome and with that I'm going
to close this hearing and the committee
is going to take a
break uh and we're going to have our
lunch and we're going to do everything
do no no we're just I'm not acting on
anything today and we don't have enough
yeah yeah's gone we'll be coming back
here in another 35 minutes at about
or in between the 9 and the
say won
tomorrow yeah okay I need a card from
you from me yes you're right this bill
right
y
back in session here at the education
committee we're going to be moving
forward here with HB 1298 this is a bill
relative to the definition of part-time
teachers and I represent represent uh I
recognize representative cordelli to
present the Bill thank you thank you Mr
chairman and honorable colleagues um uh
for the record uh Glenn cordelli
representing tufton burough wolf bur and
oy in the beautiful Lakes
Region and I'm pleased to present a
1298 um we have discussed we've seen
articles um all year on the teacher
shortages um
in many areas special
education um some Specialties in terms
of um speech and and
reading um and this is um another
attempt to try and help with that
shortage uh and we termed it part-time
teachers and that um they would be
working less than 30 hours per week
um they would have some kind of
expertise or professional experience in
the subject area that they are assigned
to uh teach
in um they would go through the normal
records criminal records background
checks um and they would also be
overseen um uh mentored by uh a
supervising teacher if you will uh to um
um we do indicate also that if they have
had their credential um
revoked um that they would not be
eligible for such a position uh but I
think that this is one small step we can
take with the um with the teacher
shortage
um how long that teacher shortage will
last and in what subject areas we don't
know but I think that this will help um
in the short term uh certainly um with
that
shortage and I thank you thank you very
much are there any questions for
representative
cordelli not see thank you very
house
good afternoon chairman laad members of
the House Education committee uh I'm
here on behalf of the members of the
American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire uh to speak in opposition to
HB 1298 I do appreciate the attempt to
find a creative solution to the teacher
shortage we have in this state and many
places in the country but um I want to
say that this is not the way to go about
it um it would not be in the best
interest of our public uh school
students and it
would overburden already overburden
full-time staff teaching is not just a
matter of knowing your content area so
limiting this to just individuals who
have specialized knowledge coming in
from another field um does not solve the
concern we have with it to be a teacher
you need not only knowledge of a Content
area you need to know about Learners and
how they learn you need to know about
child devel velopment or adolescent
development uni classroom management
skills being a credential teacher means
that youve had at least an exposure or
uh had a chance to develop an
understanding of all that in your um
college preparatory course when you
became a teacher and in your student
teaching and practicums um and as you
are um a teacher when you go to
recertify you you have to show that
you're doing ongoing professional
development to keep up with uh new
developments in the field
um let's see you know you you um just
because you are very good at a
particular field say coding in um
computers does not mean that you know
how to manage a classroom full of
students and it also does not mean that
you have the correct temperament not to
get drawn into a battle of wills with a
seventh grader who doesn't want to
listen and doesn't want to do the work
it could be a really bad setup for the
student students and end up in a bad
outcome um the idea that full-time
teaching teaching staff will just
Mentor part-time uncertified employees
who get hired as
teachers
is a a bad um idea it there there's
nothing in here that explains how that's
going to work you're adding more work to
people who are already so overworked
that many of them are considering
whether they want to stay in teaching so
please don't put more on their plates
it'll be bad for the students because
the teachers are already so
overburdened that they're having a hard
time doing everything they need to do in
our under resource public schools to
meet their current students needs never
mind supervising another
uncertified employee without the support
you would get from um a college Pro a
teacher prep program if it were a normal
student teaching
experience um and by the way putting a
full-time teacher in a supervisory
position over an uncertified staff that
you've hired as teacher um is probably
in violation of all of our Collective
baring agreements around the state so
for those reasons we are opposing HB
1298 and thank you for your time thank
you very much are there questions from
the committee not seeing thank you very
Tuttle good afternoon thank you chairman
lad members of the House Education
committee uh for the record I'm Megan
tutle president for Nea New Hampshire
representing about 17,000 Educators
across the state um just like Deb we're
also here in opposition to House Bill
1298 uh relative to the definition of
part-time teachers there's other avenues
that we can use to help ensure there's
adequate quality educated um educator
personel who are certified if you look
back at the educator shortage committee
report that came out um at the end of
the summer this fall nowhere in there
did it mention this approach of having a
part-time teacher the way the bill is
written makes it seem like because a
teacher doesn't engage in full-time
teaching activities they don't need the
appropriate credentials to engage in
teaching the question isn't really the
amount of time and a person engages in
teaching activities but rather a
question of wanting to ensure that the
person who works in the capacity of a
teacher has the Knowledge and Skills to
do so effectively licensing by the state
is one of the ways that citizens can be
assured that the person does have that
re requisite knowledge and skill
applying the Bill's logic to other
professions just really shows the
fallacy of the Bill's Logic for example
if a surgeon performs surgery on a
part-time basis should that surgeon be
licensed if a psychiatrist only sees
patients on a part-time basis should
that psychiatrist have a license to
practice putting people into teaching
positions without the requisite
Knowledge and Skills will not end up
helping students and these people are
more likely to leave the job and the
profession sooner this has been shown in
studies was testified to in the teacher
shortage committee by superintendant as
well we already have a one-year
Certificate of Eligibility that is
available to local school districts
should they need it and which the
legislature just recently added a
one-year extension to in the 2023
session we also have alternative
certification Pathways so this bill to
us seems really unnecessary paragraph
three of the bill States the local
school shall appoint a supervising
teacher to oversee and participate in EV
evaluation of each part-time teacher's
work and
Effectiveness what are the
qualifications of that supervising
teacher can they be another part-time
teacher will they be compensated with
shortages do they even have time or do
we have people willing to do this what
is involved in the overseeing and the
evaluation and again as you know debb
mentioned um there are employment
Provisions covered under cvas one last
thing for the code of conduct we're
wondering how the code of conduct
conduct would be enforced on a part-time
teacher is the department suggesting
that they take action on someone that
doesn't have a certification and how
would the department do what is claimed
as necessary before this committee
numerous times prevent someone who
violates the code at one school from
being hired at another because under
this that person is not required to hold
a license that the state board can
suspend or revoke so instead of this
approach the instead of the approach
this bill takes we need to be focusing
on helping school districts raise pay
invest in teacher Recruitment and
training improving working conditions
for school staff and that can increase
the numbers and diversity of fully
prepared teachers and Par professionals
as well as working with pre-service
educator programs and programs like
Educators rising in the high schools
thank you very much are there
questions for Megan n thank you very
much I'll get written testimony
submitted thank you yep you said you
Wilson
[Music]
uh good afternoon members of the House
head committee for the record Becky
Wilson director of governmental
relations for the New Hampshire school
boards Association uh thanks for the
opportunity to testify today we
certainly appreciate the intent of
trying to work towards solutions to fill
positions that are of critical need in
the state however we are opposed to this
bill uh we certainly we have a
resolution which focuses on supporting
legislation that intends to streamline
recruiting credentialing and hiring but
of certified staff not of uncertified
Staff as you've heard by several people
prior to me uh there are opportunities
and Pathways for people to take if they
would like to become a certified teacher
um or an educator in the state we share
the concerns about what happens if
somebody violates the code of conduct
while we appreciate that this bill tries
to wrap these part-time teachers under
that umbrella I'm not sure what is being
suspended or taken away if the only um
thing that currently can be suspended or
taken away as your license and you're
not required to be licensed I also
wanted to point out um in terms of some
of the critical shortage areas special
ed for example regardless of whether or
not the state wants those people to be
certified the federal idea requires them
to be certified and licensed in certain
areas in order to provide the services
and students IEPs so this wouldn't
really address that concern uh 30 hours
is a significant amount of time if you
have a person that works uh Bell to Bell
for example and the school day is 30 to
3 that's 35 hours so 30 hours a week is
a significant amount of time uh in a
student's school day that you could be
working with somebody who has not had
any teacher prep programming um and
teacher prep programming really uh
certainly focuses on all of the safety
concerns that we've talked about but
also just the P pedagogy concerns um
some of the bills that have come from
this committee most recently around very
specific uh instructional strategies
ways to deal with uh interventions
concerns of students who potentially
aren't meeting uh concerning benchmarks
Etc um a person who is not certified or
has no intention of going through a
teacher prep program would have no uh
necessarily no exposure to those things
so that's why we would oppose this Bill
thank you very much are there questions
for the school boards
Association not seeing any thank you
very
much uh Steve Appleby from the
Department
good afternoon chair and representatives
thank you uh Steve app from the
Department of Education uh just want to
provide a couple of um technical items
uh the first one is um RSA 189 colon 39b
is the one-ear Certificate of
Eligibility that was expanded to two
years last year um here in the house and
the Senate both um that allows an
individual ual to uh take the role as an
educator without having a license um
they're still subject to a uh criminal
history record check and the issuance of
a criminal history record check
clearance by the department um and that
can be
revoked this bill mentions background
check again or equ history record check
a clearance would be issued similar what
we're doing now for lots of different uh
categories such as uh student teachers
bus drivers beginning educators their
first license we we run that check issue
a clearance we do have the ability to
revoke that uh in our administrative
rules so um that would be I believe the
thinking from a misconduct standpoint as
we revoke the clearance which then means
they can't
work so I'm happy to answer any other
questions are there representative Miler
thank you Mr chair thank you for being
here could you review for the committee
the alternative certification process
that one would go through sure thank you
representative so um currently we have
what's called site-based
licensing and that is very similar to an
on the- job type of um system whereby a
district hires an individual who has a
degree and a certain number of credits
in the content area that they'll be
teaching and that person is uh put on a
development plan and can spend up to
three years they work under a mentoring
teacher so they're a teacher mentors all
over the state um and that individual
Works towards lure over 3 years working
full-time time uh in a school and while
they're doing that they're also meeting
the pieces of their plan so their plan
uh may have some elements that are uh
coursework related it may have some
experience requirements uh project
requirements that type of thing whatever
the mentor and the principal or
superintendent deem appropriate that
will meet the lens your standard uh we
currently have about 1500 or so
individuals Statewide on a site based
plan so um but that that is typically a
three-year process follow go ahead uh so
as a followup with this proposal an
individual will not have to go through
that alternative certification pathway
is that correct that is correct yes
thank you further questions represent
Ford thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question it's a very specific question
that I'm asking it has to do with those
people who teach
what might be called subspecialties in
technical Fields welding for example if
you needed someone to teach hel Arch
welding rather than just simple welding
you might have to go find someone who
knew how to do hel Arch welding they
would have been trained in a trade
school but you need them to teach in the
high
school what does this process provide
for you by the way of an alternative to
get to someone who has a background in
teaching teaching of people of the same
age group
even but now they're teaching in a
different setting does this enable you
to do
that does it make it at least possible
to recruit such a person and then have
them take online or on their own at
night or whenever the cours is to become
certified at the second
level uh thank thank you for the
question if I'm understanding correctly
what you're asking is if someone who has
this life experience from a career
potentially
um this this would allow them I again if
I'm understanding correctly this would
allow let's say it's a non-ct high
school but they wanted to add a welding
class they could bring an individual
with welding experience in part-time
without a license to teach that class
thank you very
much for the questions I got a follow-up
question for you two of them so if I'm
looking
for a Spanish teacher as a high school
principal and there's no Spanish teacher
out there but if I have a science
teacher who has a fluent understanding
Spanish that is licensed to teach
science that person can that person also
teach Spanish if it's if he teaches in
his area certified in more than 50% of
the
time thank you for the question so we
have an administrative rule called we
call the minor assignment rule uh and
that is in the uh 8300s and that allows
for a licensed individual to teach
outside their area of lure up to 49.9%
of their workload so so they could be
and in fact we see this frequently
around the state where an individual is
licensed in one area
and they teach four classes in that area
and they teach one class outside of
their licensed area the second question
I have when I got my principal ticket
over in Maine on my master's program it
came out as a supervising principal
that's what it was back in those days
that's what they called it in this state
do you know through your working in the
area of certification can another
teacher evaluate another teacher or does
it have to be somebody with that super
vising responsibility that's part of
their
endorsement uh thank you I I don't know
the specific answer to that question
that seems like more of an employment
question but what I can tell you is we
have over 1500 individuals on site based
plans who do have a mentoring
experienced
educator overseeing uh their plan and
their progress through the plan
currently that's overseeing but it's not
evaluating there whe they're going to go
I I think there's some gray there yeah
further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank
you I have no more pink cards in this
one so we're going to close this
hearing get a little bit
closer uh we'll do 1458 that's relative
to authorizing parents to remove
children from the English language
learner
program
and I see representative Leon
welcome thank you Mr chairman and
members of the education committee I
bring this bill forward today because of
my friend and her son um he is a very
capable very intelligent young man who
was the top of his class in both reading
and writing his mom who is an amazing
strong powerful business business owning
woman who is not a native English
speaker had messed up filling out the
forms and when it said what is your
child's native language she wrote her
native language Spanish on it it went
for a few years and um as her son was
testing he got to be very uncomfortable
in the testing that's used it's where
you go into a computer lab with other
kids with headphones and microphones on
and you need to speak and give your
answers in English
speaking into an empty room with
uncomfortable headphones into a
microphone I know I've been
uncomfortable in that situation and I'm
not surprised to hear that children are
all uncomfortable in that situation he
wouldn't speak because he was
uncomfortable so year after year he
failed the English uh proficiency test
on the computer because he didn't want
to speak yet he was a top performing
student in both reading and writing in
his class his mom went to the
Schoolboard and worked with them and
because it had been so much time since
he had initially filled out that form um
you couldn't just go through the normal
process that she identified when she
enrolled her his younger sister in and
um her the younger sister was
immediately pulled back out of the El
program and was um going through the
normal process because the daughter just
like the son were native English
speakers in a bilingual household um
he's now moved on to Junior High and she
thought he'd be out of vll and would be
unnecessary but he's still in the elll
program he hasn't res received services
at all and I would bet you that he's not
alone I think that it's very critical
that for our students who need
assistance getting up to speed with
English language learning that they have
all the resources that they need but I
think that having some students that are
sort of Trapped in this program who
don't actually need the services does a
disservice for that child and more
importantly for those who actually need
this instruction we need to make sure
that every child who needs instruction
to get up to speed and up to grade level
in English gets that assistance and
that's why this is sort of a two-part
Bill the first says that if a student is
performing at grade level in reading and
writing then they'll be out if the
parent requests it or if they um have
not been provided the El Services I
think the larger issue would be if there
are student that really really need this
help and have gone for years without
having elll Services I recognize that we
have teaching shortages and that's why I
would retain the ability for the school
district to appeal that these students
would be automatically removed for not
receiving two years of elll service um
and I would assume that the State Board
would automatically grant that if
they've been trying to find people to
teach these students but if we start
finding that multiple districts are
having this problem then we may find
that there's a crisis under our nose
with the our elll program you know
integrating students into our community
and making sure that they have the
skills to succeed as critical and
starting off especially with young
students making sure that they are
learning in English and that they have
received the skills that they need in
order to do so as soon as possible is
critical you know we see what two years
of being out of the classroom is done to
kids what about 2 years of sitting and
not really understanding what's
happening because you need somebody to
help you key on to understand English
when you're in the classroom you know we
need to make sure that both those
students at grade level can get out if
their parents want them to and that
we're providing the needed services for
those students who need them so I think
that hopefully there'll be very little
impact from this bill but I think that
it's important to both give that option
for parents to remove their High
performing students from the program and
to sort of send up a flag and a signal
if we we have a lot of students who are
not being given um that given that
instruction which we as a state owe to
them so with that I'd be happy take
questions just for everybody here we do
have the department here to a answer
specific questions regarding this
program whether it be the statute or how
it's being administered so that's
available questions of the
representative representative kiss Kaden
thank you Mr chair thank you y thank you
for taking my question so I am a
certified ESO teacher and still uh
provide assessments with weda and school
districts that can't find
somebody for a student to be removed
from a program there is a process in the
laow plan both the state plan and the
district plan if they have one that
specifies how it how a parent can go
about having their child removed from
the services now Federal Law requires
that you test every student that doesn't
have a composite score for
4.5 however if the student is doing
really well
academically testing I get it sometimes
kids freeze up but there should be uh an
incentive for that child to go through
that testing process it's pretty
interactive and visual
cartoony um that if they're doing well
in reading and writing in the regular
classroom through RTI or whatever
program they have they should reach that
composite score but in terms of
reclassification a parent has the right
to decline the services and then that
happens and the form goes in the student
file so I'm not sure what this would do
different from what allow plan says you
can do well um thank you for that that
question um this mom spent three years
trying to get her son out of the program
and she was told that the only process
that she could have would be to appeal
to the State Board of Education but she
was unable to get a time to go to the
State Board of educ education and the
process kept getting dropped um it seems
that this process is overly complex and
it seems that there may be some
challenges and I appreciate how much
train training goes into being an ESO
teacher my mom actually retired recently
from teaching in California where she
was in the only grade level English only
class because even as the English only
teacher she needed to be changed in esol
because it was such a migrant community
so it is challenging and it's good to
know that there are some safeguards but
um even in some of our largest districts
with the highest number of esol students
that's either not known or not being um
followed through on so I see I see a
need representative Cornell thank you
and thank you for taking my question um
having been in the Manchester school
district for 36 years I can agree with
rep cascaden that there are so many
students of need of services that they
do not keep anybody in the program that
doesn't need to be there um because
there's just so many people in the
program and and this is it isn't really
a but would you believe that when a
parent wanted their child out of that
program it happened very quickly and it
was pretty easy thing to do and there
was regular testing and if anybody
tested out they were taken out they
might have been taken out and watched
for a certain amount of time to make
sure that they were doing okay but
nobody was ever kept in against their
will um thank you would it be possible I
know that this bill we don't need to act
on until the middle of March would it be
possible for you and me and the parent
to work with the Manchester School
District because that's where her son is
enrolled to understand what's going on
and what the disconnect is because
there's clearly a disconnect we are the
people who we are part of the people who
can do something about it and if we can
identify a problem I'd love to work with
you on either figuring out at the
district level or at the state level
what to do thank you further questions
rep
I guess this will have to be a would you
believe um yet another parent which I
almost thought that's who she was
talking about but the language was
Hungarian and the question was what
language was spoken at home well it was
Hungarian didn't mean they didn't speak
English son was put in Hungarian and the
mom could not I mean over two years have
gone by his English was fine his dad
speaks English and yet he could not she
had the hardest time trying to get him
out of that program so it wasn't
Manchester but it does happen and it's
not just okay we need a question now um
so would you believe that it's not just
one I I believe that maybe we need to
look at more than just Manchester but
let's start there and figure out where
the disconnect is and then see if that's
something to that needs to be dealt with
across the state any further questions
from R and Leon thank you very much
thank you um I'd like to call U Melissa
white from the no excuse me Aubrey
fredman
first uh Mr chair uh committee members
Aubrey Friedman Bridgewater I speak in
support of this bill and I'm happy to
support this one rather than the one
this morning that I spoke in favor of um
it's one thing to take away Services uh
or not offer but actually this is
somebody who this is a circumstance
where the parent says I don't want the
services
so it should in my mind this should be
why make it hard for them I mean the
parent knows their child better than
anybody else and generally parents want
more services not less so if they say I
don't need this anymore why make it hard
let's make it easy let the kid out um on
the fiscal note um it's talking about
State funding please for once let's keep
politics out of this let's
just honor individuality if the kid
doesn't need it let's make it easy and
this bill seems to do it and then again
it does have this um clause about the
school district is able to appeal if
there is some kind of um unusual reason
that they feel that the kids should uh
still be left in the program so there
could that could maybe cover some
unusual circumstance so uh that's why I
support the bill I say let the kid out
if the parent says they don't need it
and let somebody else in you're actually
taking a spot so that's why I support
the Bill thank you very much are there
any questions thank you thank you
Melissa
white good afternoon Melissa white
division director for learner support at
the Department of Education I just um
available to answer questions I think um
the information that was provided um
kind of summed it up but I can provide a
little bit more clarification with
regards to I just want to make a
distinction between services and
identification so a student that is
identified as an English language
learner and then providing services are
are kind of two separate things parents
can say they do not want Services they
do not want their child to be provided
with any type of language supports so
they can say they do not want those
services so just wanted to to clarify
that that's a little bit different than
um saying identification wise you can't
opt out of of an identification if
you're identified as an English language
learner you meet all of the criteria um
one of the things that is part of that
identification process is that home
language survey the home language survey
there is one question about you know
what language is spoken in the home but
there are multiple other questions that
go on with the home language survey that
are pretty detailed so it's not just the
one question and the students
automatically identified as an English
language learner there's multiple pieces
to that in addition to an English
language learner screener that's
provided before they're ever identified
so there's a pretty um involved process
it's just not check a box and you're
automatically identified so I'm going to
clarify that piece of it um the other
part with regards to students um who
have not received the El L services in
the preceding two years shall be
automatically removed from the program
um that could potentially create some
issues for the state as that would go
against some of the requirements that
are in Essa and could potentially impact
Federal funding so I just want to be
clear that um if a student is identified
and they're not receiving those services
that is okay but for us to remove them
from identification we're not allowed to
do that piece of it so just want to
clarify they have to actually have um um
as representative cascaden mentioned
they have to have some of those
qualifying factors for being um taken
out of that identification process if a
student is proficient in reading and
writing and that is shown on any type of
Assessments whether they be the progress
monitoring that's happening within the
school district or the Statewide
assessment then they would um
automatically be exited from
identification and services and then
kind of put on a
monitoring um watch but they wouldn't be
required to continue to take the
assessment so if the students did uh
come out proficient on that assessment
then they wouldn't be technically
required to take that test so that's a
piece we can work through with parents
and um in particular if there's any
issues or concerns that come up we can
always at the department help to to kind
of um process those with those
families thank you very much much most I
do have a question for you I've heard
the word monitoring several times today
and in special ed that became quite an
issue years back where kids would put on
monitor
for years thereafter and collecting the
money from the state for absolutely no
contact from the therapist or whomever
it may be that was a common
practice uh is while a a student is put
on monitoring do they receive uh are
they still identified as a person that
is receiving English language learner uh
support and if so are they receiving
funding through adequacy for it part no
adequacy I do not believe I would like
to double check that with our our team
but I'm pretty sure that um once the
student is exited from Services we keep
a monitoring status so that's if within
let's say the next two or three four
years that student ends
up not doing well and their teachers and
their team team decide maybe they could
benefit from some supports then we can
look at reidentifying them and putting
them back into elll services but that
wouldn't be decided without you know the
students um educational team and the
family being involved with that process
so it's really looking at their their
their how well they're doing in school
that's what the monitoring is for
different from special education
represent my thank you Mr chair thank
you for being here
a couple or two clarifying questions
please when you heard represent lon's uh
uh report on the particular individual
that that's a an acquaintance of theirs
first question what is the incident rate
that you've heard of this kind of a
problem where a parent wants to have
their child removed that's question one
question two is uh is there a universal
process for the removal of a child from
uh an El program or is that left up to
the policies of the local school
district thank you for your answer thank
you for the question so with regards to
accepting services so if a student has
is identified and they've gone through
the identification and the screening
process the services are offered but the
parents can at that time opt to not take
the service they they can say you know I
don't want my my child to be serviced
and that so that's that's a part of that
that process and uh developing the
individualized language learning plan
with that student
um so usually the district is involved
the school is involved with making that
determination of those services with the
family and then families at that time
usually can say they do not want um
those Services um we do I can't I
couldn't put a number on it because I
don't track the the calls that we get in
but if we get concerns coming in from
time to time not frequently um we we'll
just help to kind of negotiate or to to
um mediate that with the district and
with the family so that they are aware
of all the Avenues that are available to
them but it's usually something we're
able to to work with the districts on
and work with the families on thank you
further questions from the committee ref
leus thank you for taking my question
I'm trying to make sure I I understand
this in the beginning they fill out this
questionnaire they could be
identified but the parents May say he
doesn't need this we don't we won't want
to do the services and in fact the child
could be doing perfectly fine in school
um but you said they still have to be
identified correct so the question
is does the state as far as far
as the bump that you get for elll do
they get that if you're identified or
only if you're providing services so I'm
looking more at the the component for
title three in the identification for um
the esa title program so title 3 is a
federal fund that we received to support
students um of course Manchester and NWA
um receive the largest allocations of
title 3 funding in addition to there's
um some reporting components for for
title 1A um in supporting those students
in acquiring uh English proficiency so
I'm coming at it from that lens I would
like to um look a little bit more
closely on the the state adequacy side
um because it's my my understanding but
I want to make sure and not speak
incorrectly but I I'm coming and
testifying on that that lens so kind of
that Federal funding lens thank you very
much sorry so Melissa I'm I would like
to pursue the adequacy side of this
issue
I see Caitlyn back
there Caitlyn do you have any kind of
right okay Dr Green will take you stuff
it good afternoon so the question is if
they're identified as bre and leus just
mentioned but they choose not to take
that program are we then using adequacy
dollars to support that person being
identified as a elll student so in this
case when we're talking about State
adequacy funding the initial
identification comes from administering
the screener and the screener is what uh
tells the school district whether or not
that student needs services so the
parent can opt out of those services but
the screener still says that the student
was identified as an elll learner so as
an active elll learner that school would
receive the adequacy funding tied to an
apportionment represent
leus so once the parent comes in and
says take them out of this does that
adequacy money go away or does it follow
them for the rest of their schooling or
how does that work so each year
thereafter even if the student isn't
receiving Services they'll still take a
test each year to determine what level
of English proficiency they have um so
the parents are just opting out of the
services provided by the program it may
be that in you know a year or two years
or three years that student is testing
proficient in English and at that point
they wouldn't be identified as an El
learner anymore and the district would
not continue to receive that state
adequacy money but there is a testing
component that still occurs each
year thank you are there further
questions of the
department
thank you very much both of you thank
you thank you so I have no more pink
cards on this one so we're going to
close this
1496 let's see who's the represent
presenting that bill I know
it
representative ho
welcome good
[Music]
afternoon good afternoon for the record
and representative poll serving the
towns of dun Barton hooks at Allenstown
in
Epson I'm here in support of House Bill
1496 it's a very simple Bill only adds
sentences and this is relative to what
does the state's obligation have to
protect the students in the care during
school there's been an ongoing issue
that goes back even to the mid90s um
there is a case and I will send the
members of this committee a copy of this
case um marway versus Eno from 19
1995 um back then um several young girls
were um abused by various employees
within the depart or within the school
system and the parents couldn't find
relief and they couldn't find relief and
they ultimately took it up through the
federal courts and the federal courts
asked the New Hampshire Supreme Court
what was their opinion of various
statutes and is there any obligation or
duty to protect the children while the
and
unfortunately it's not real
clear the bottom line is even with this
case and several others that have been
built on this case it's not real
clear what is the duty for the school
system to make sure the children are
safe and I do believe that there is an
obligation I believe every parent in the
state believes there's an
obligation but unfortunately it's not in
our
statutes I'm not sure if this is the
proper language I would reach out maybe
to the doe to make sure that um they
have legal counsel or maybe there's
somebody else who who can weigh in from
the AG's office if if this is in fact
the best way to do this
language it was the best we could draft
during the OS drafting
period um in terms of using terms like
reasonable care to protect the child
during the school
hours um
and that goes back to the one Supreme
Court case that I'm going to mention to
you there may be a better way to do
this the reason this bill is here is
when parents drop their children off at
school they're gone they're they're not
there for the day the school is acting
as the parental Guardian during those
hours the child is in the
classroom and that would TR that would
be true on a sports athletic field with
a coach for instance after work but in
the case of after school activities the
parent has made the decision to have the
children there and unfortunately the
case that I'm referencing had to do with
um at least one of the three children
had to do with
um a coach in an after school activity
but in the case of the education during
the hours that the children are
learning the state has made a
requirement that the children be there
we don't have learning requirements
ments in the state of New Hampshire um
we have education we have truancy
requirements we have compulsory
attendance requirements there's a lot of
things we could say but we don't have a
requirement today to teach the child we
have a requirement that they show up and
be in the
classroom um that's what our laws say it
would be great if they learned that's
important I'm not diminishing the
importance of education but I'm saying
our laws are treny based laws and we
require students to show up during a
certain number of hours and that is in
keeping with Supreme Court decisions
about if you're compelling a person to
be someplace then the state takes on a
new obligation relative to the
production of that of that
individual I would ask that you at a
minimum study this because this needs
some time and attention because there's
clearly a gap in our statutes between
what parents expect relative to the
protection of their children and what
the current statutes say and or other
decisions that have happened both at the
New Hampshire Supreme Court and the US
Supreme Court relative to what is the
children as I said earlier this came out
of os this was the best place we could
think to put this in the statutes I sat
on this committee a decade ago there may
be a better place I'm open to that um
this is kind of at the highest level and
it wasn't real clear within let's say
193 or some of the other places where
this could go hav touch these statutes
at the level you guys do for for a
decade but I believe there probably this
is at least one place to put it there
might be a better place to put this
language relative to um when we're and
potentially in the treny sections um if
we're compelling kids to be in the
classroom because it's good and
important then we make we should be
making sure that they're safe in that
classroom thank you very much and with
that I'll end my testimony represent
leus I do have a question with the
wording if we go with this wording does
that give the state as acting in local
parenes the ability to give medicines
vaccines Etc during the time that the
child is in school that's a great
question um and for the record locco
parenes should be in italics I think um
it is a good question I don't have an
answer for that that would be
I would run that by the doe in terms of
if
it's if this is considered the fully
acting have we transferred that much
authority to the classroom these are the
questions that need to be vetted on this
it's a great question further
questions thank you very much
Association
welcome thank you chairman lad good
afternoon members of the committee bar
Christina uh from the school boards
Association we're not taking a position
on this bill uh I just wanted to come
and comment a couple of things I want to
thank representative hall for the for
the bill in general and um also
recognizing that he um that the bill may
may need some work and the language may
not be specific because those were a
couple of the things that jumped out to
nsba uh when we were reviewing the bill
um the the first thing that I might want
to just sort of clarify were whereas the
bill talks about the state requirements
and the state is acting as temporary
Guardian in local parus the the the law
the case that representative hle
mentions Mar Eno um the court sort of
drilled that down a little bit and it's
it's the school district that is
actually acting in in local parentis and
not the state is sort of the larger
entity because the school district is
the one that's responsible for
overseeing the employees making sure
that the students are being properly uh
supervised so on and so forth so that
was one one aspect um uh of of
clarification that I wanted to bring to
the committee um the other aspects um
that we just wanted to clarify and
representative lakus your your question
um about sort of vaccines and Medicine
um were kind of in the along the lines
of of some of the things NH hsba was was
thinking um know I don't know if
corporal punishment is still used in
schools anymore it is allowed under New
Hampshire law RSA 627 colon 6 paragraph
2A does still allow for corporal
punishment in school districts nhba will
not Advocate that that occurs but I just
want to put that out there for acting a
local parentice we might have the uh the
the reasonable justification for taking
wood spoon to the kid who's to the kid
who's who's Who's acting up um uh
perhaps um uh more controversial um you
mentioned the vaccines representative
lakus I wrote down what about masking
requirements um that was a bit of a
contention in school districts maybe
three years ago um so just some other
considerations there is I don't want to
call it a direct conflict between what
I'll just call quote unquote parental
rights versus in local parentis but as
representative whole recognized there
may be there's going to have to be some
give and take there if we're giving
school districts local par full and
local parentice responsibilities between
the you know hours of 8 and three versus
what some of the other parental rights
would be in terms of curriculum and
opting out of courses and we had some
bills this morning that sort of touched
on some of those things didn't we so
anyway we're not taking a position on
the bill um it was more just for nsba to
provide um some level of background and
clarification for the committee and I'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
I'll start out with one question is the
terminology local parenes
in
statute now it it is not it's a it's a
common law phrase in the location of the
parents um and I just did a quick search
um I don't think the the I don't think
that phrase per se or directly is used
um in the marqu v Eno case but in some
of the what we called I think we called
them headnotes when I was in law school
um it says um
uh where is it um authority of schools
the duty of supervision falls upon those
School Employees who have super
supervisory responsibility over over
students and who have stepped into the
role of Parental proxy is what the the
language of of of the case is using um
and it says School Employees who share
parental proxy who share a parental
proxy relationship with the student and
who learn of facts um which would lead a
reasonable person to conclude the
student is being abused are subject to
liability if their supervision is
unreasonable and it is approximate cause
of the students injury so um so whereas
representative hold to your question
though in local parentice is not used in
statute and while we don't have any sort
of overarching statutes about the school
district's responsibility to keep
students safe when the student is in the
custody of of the uh uh of of the school
or not the custody but in the the care
and supervision of the school district
we do have the teacher code of conduct
as well too in the administrative rules
that there's Provisions in there about
keeping students safe broadly in
generally but in statute not directly no
as an
attorney could you please help me out
with this then whenever we went in years
ago because local parentice was in a lot
of State statutes elsewhere at one time
not now and I was always advised by the
people across the street don't use that
don't put that terminology into statute
why would they say that um that's a good
question I don't know I'd like to hear
that reasoning myself to be to be quite
honest with with
you okay I haven't done a admittedly I
haven't done a full research on in local
parenes I did some some quick research
over the weekend would and do like a
deep dive into it nationwide or read any
legal journals or anything on it just a
quick preparation for the Bill thank you
further questions from the committee not
seeing your hands thank you very much
and that is all we have on that
particular bill so we conclude that one
and get on to the next bill which is
1692 I'm going introduce that yeah we're
getting
you
okay HB
1692 is relative to public high school
graduation
requirements here stack next bill okay
representa Cordell you're
uh thank you Mr chairman honorable
colleagues um for the record Glenn
cordelli representing Tuftonboro wolf
bro and oi in the beautiful Lakes Region
and um um representative verville um was
unable to be here today so he asked me
to um introduce this bill for him and um
I think this goes along with um some
other bills that we've had over the past
two years uh trying to look at um
satisfying High School requirements and
minimum
competencies
um um this is really the first time I'm
reading the bill so I I think I'll leave
that are there any questions of
represent
cordelli not seeing it thank you very
much thank you very much do we have any
bill pardon me let's see oh that was
okay that was on top
Freedman
yeah Mr chairman committee members
Aubrey Friedman Bridgewater I'm also
happy to support this bill um well we
need to have some kind of minimum re
requirements to get a high school
diploma and the way it is now kids are
just graduating with po really not
prepared um and I've got the scores here
for my own School District the high
school Ela 68% and that's as high as
I've seen it in a long time math
32% 32% these are 11th graders unless
they really drastically improved in 12th
grade um that's and that's the late ones
off the uh Department of Education
website and science is
44% so we've got to raise the standards
I think having a minimum the 25th
percentile is it's a pretty low bar uh
but it at least it's something I mean
we're paying a fortune if you think
about it like 20,000 a year times 13
years is what I don't know quarter of a
million or something like that there
should be something for the taxpayers to
show that the students are ready to move
on into the Adult World um the bill does
include a remedial plan so it's not like
suddenly it just okay folks if you don't
meet this you're going to be out of luck
it does offer a remedial plan uh to get
those scores up and it doesn't seem to
limit the number of times the student
could take the uh exam so uh so
presumably you could take it a few times
until you could get your diploma so it
doesn't throw them out in the cold it's
got a minimum and uh as far as the
fiscal note I'm generally not crazy
about additional Education costs uh but
there would be some and I guess in this
case it might be worth it and in the
long run I think the estimates are I
think it's like 412,000 then it goes to
300,000 a year and then 200,000 a year
presumably I think if the proper
incentive to get that High School imp
ploma uh will make kids work harder and
maybe they won't take need to take the
test so many extra times so maybe the
cost will be less than anticipated so I
think it's it's time to have a minimum
for a diploma and that's why I support
this Bill thank you are there any
questions of Mr
fredman not seeing thank you very much
thank you uh Becky Wilson from New
Hampshire school boards Association do
uh thank you for hearing my testimony
for the record Becky Wilson uh New
Hampshire school boards Association uh
we're opposed to this bill I won't go
line by line I'll just sort of Hit the
highlights I think of things that we've
discussed previously uh in regards to a
one-time assessment um qualifying a
student to get a diploma um there's some
confusion for for us with this bill um
in terms of using the the Statewide
assessment also as the graduation
requirement assessment right now the
majority of um high schools in New
Hampshire public high schools are using
the SAT as their Statewide assessment
it's given in 11th grade um this would
appeared if you use the bill as written
that the student would take the SAT in
11th grade and somehow use that to
graduate even though they have not been
exposed to the curriculum of the 12th
grade um and most of the testing is done
in October typically of 11th grade to
measure 10th grade assessment so I'm a
little I think there's a little
confusion there in terms of how this how
this bill would change our current
practice of giving a Statewide
assessment for high school um it's not
given at every grade uh this committee's
also spent an exorbitant amount of time
talking about Competency Based education
what that means what that looks like um
how a student can prove competency uh I
think there's been a lot of discussion
about the fact that a one-time multiple
choice assessment taken on a computer
does not necessarily show that a student
is competent in the high school
competencies that are uh quite honestly
derived at the local level and are part
of getting a local high school diploma
from The Local District uh the Local
District should be able to decide what
their diploma requirements are um and
not base them on a one-time state test
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you are there any questions for the
school boards Association representative
Cornell Thank you thank you for taking
my question and also on assessments
parents have the ability to opt out of
taking tests thank you for the question
yes and this bill does reference that
that a parent could opt their child out
of taking the Statewide assessment which
is an option now as well I'm not sure
then what the student would need to do
in order to prove their competency to
graduate from high school um and get a
local District
diploma further
questions not see any thank you very
much thank you there any other cards in
this bill we'll close this bill
we are ahead of schedule how did
I by minutes three minutes three minutes
to get up
and
done
Coes nures there's n vacancies yeah I
thought there were whole s that's what
we had told to
us
yeah
okay
way who's that back there is that K uh
back there and who probably yeah is he
talking yeah he got
co-sponsor
I'm going to go get a copy that's the
one I don't
have get you had to go get one too she
never gave us these bills I never got
one either did you get 16 no I yeah I
yeah anybody how many people don't have
really I probably mpil
do
okay I had the fiscal note on it mhm
yeah me too but not the bill yeah
okay
mofet Prime sponsor of 1682 relative to
the Civics test graduation
requirement thank you Mr cheer that is
true and congratulations for running
ahead of schedule that's wonderful to
see that when that happens uh for the
record uh I'm repr Mike Mett uh M
District 4 um canterberry and Lowden so
this measure involves RSA 189 colon 11
paragraph 2 which refers to the required
Civics competency assessment which
became law last term uh some of you will
recall that this graduation requirement
mandates all students high school
students achieve a 70 or better in the
2020 128 question naturalization
examination developed by our United
States citizen and Immigration
Services uh as an aside uh after local
districts processed and integrated this
requirement over the course of the past
year we've received some uh some nice
anecdotal feedback that the integration
of this into the plan seems to be going
pretty well and there's actually some
excitement believe it or not about this
people taking this new um
assessment um also anecdotally um just
yesterday I called my niece uh Malia
she's an honor student at conquered High
School um but she and my sister-in-law
meta just moved back to New Hampshire
from Denmark last year so I asked my
niece about this Civics requirement
which I had some interested in and she
said she just started a civics class
here in conquer and that she had not
taken the test yet but that she was
looking forward to it or so she said to
me maybe she just was saying that but I
she she's a honor student so anyway uh I
I of course was interested I asked if
there was much feedback uh from her
classmates and she said she didn't sense
any uh issues um and I pointed out that
I was the original sponsor so they can
extend credit or blame to me what
whatever so anyway I know this committee
does a lot of bills um and most of them
don't necessarily get into pedagogy or
learning uh but this this law does and
so with this new Universal requirement
every New Hampshire high school graduate
is pretty much guaranteed now to have
that solid foundation of basic Civics
and history fundamentals that was often
lacking in in some districts before this
law was passed so anyway this creates a
new source I think we think of Pride and
accomplishment while enhancing the value
of a New Hampshire high school
diploma and increasing confidence in and
support for our schools so uh we
submitted this measure 1682 at the
request of Department of Education which
sought some shank some sanction for the
Department for doe to develop a
digitized version for the greater
convenience of all the schools and
school districts uh Dr Nate green is
here as well and I'm sure he can also
help to answer some questions about this
uh it's kind of like a housekeeping
measure but I know there's a couple
pieces of it that you may have some
questions on and I'll try to be happy to
try to answer any questions if if there
are any are there questions from the
committee represent
Damon thank you thank you for taking my
question maybe folks who were involved
in this previously know what I don't
know I'm a little surprised that it's
not digital already how is the test
administered now sure thank you for the
question um
that requirement that is now are is
being met a little bit differently I
think from um District to District
school to school which is why this
measure would help to create a a a
common version um I'm going to read you
if I could um a message that I received
from Dr Green who was here copy to Diana
Fenton uh because I had when they asked
to put this in for the digitized version
I had some I had some questions too so
uh from Dr Green and he's here as well
um the request for a digital version of
the test was made in order to have a
consistent measure for all teachers to
use currently to your excellent question
um teachers are giving the test to their
students in a variety of different ways
or modifying it in various ways since
the federal version of the test is given
orally those of you who are when the
this committee a couple years ago
remember that uh the federal version of
test to immigrants and and people people
trying to become citizens it's given to
them Orly they pick out like 10
questions and they have to get six right
for our students we uh have in statute
that they have to take uh all 128
questions and study all 128
questions
um so it's not possible to use that
approach of giving the test orally uh
with 128 questions from a Time
perspective the accommodations and
modifications in the statute were there
so that schools could modify their local
assessment uh when we put this into
statute we we I specifically uh made
Provisions for IEPs so that um students
could with IEPs could have uh the exam
the assessment administered in
accordance with their
IEPs uh so back to Dr Green those
accommodations are all built into the
state's assessment system so there is no
need for schools to create the
accommodations anymore since they will
be in the system and tied directly to a
student's
IEP and finally regarding the fiscal
note again this is from Dr Green I do
not believe there would be a fiscal
impact locally the same teachers that
were giving the test previously will
likely be the same teachers that will be
administering the digital version of the
test let me know if you'd like to meet
to discuss any of these points prior to
the bill becoming in bill being
introduced in committee so
uh I I emailed Dr Green he's here as
I've said three times um and hopefully
that answers your question
representative Damon
somewhat further questions from the
committee representa cordelli uh thank
you thank you for being here
representative Moffet so really the
there's two main things in here one that
it's a digital common digital
assessment um and secondly um removing
the uh local um option
is that correct yes uh you can see
what's been crossed out um in the in the
stat in the U bill as
introduced um
and I'm GNA defer to Dr Green if he's
still here and yes yes he is thank
goodness uh I I'll defer to him I I
think he he could answer that better and
he's right here F further questions from
the committee representative Miler yeah
uh just as an aside I'm surprised that
you didn't put in an amendment here that
would mandate that anybody who runs for
office should pass this test thank you
represent my believe it or not and I
know you believe it that has come up
numerous times that we should take that
exam and I support that but that's just
me
so what we're going to do though is
we're going to put a bill in so members
of this committee can get paid a stien
from the education trust fund perhaps
third 3% to 4% of the annual in interest
wouldn't that be
great I've also heard it said that we
should take a competency test
too that's that's if you're running for
president I think further question I do
have one on on this though
um the this comes underneath the section
and I'm not objecting to this test at
all I think it's good but are we
communicating to the public that this is
being used as a digital
assessment of the teaching of History
New Hampshire history because we talk
history and government of the United
States and New Hampshire does the test
you're referencing here the immigration
test All Those Questions reference any
history for New Hampshire thank you for
the question with regard to the
immigration test referencing history if
you look at the 128 questions that a lot
of them are with regard to government
structure uh a lot of them are about
history and the beauty of this is that
uh students have it's like a driver's
test in a sense you know you get a a
manual that you need to study to get a
driver's license and here it's driver's
licenses you teach to the test so to
speak and the body of knowledge here the
128 questions does include a lot of
history so any student or every student
who needs to pass this exam needs to be
familiar with and study the uh the body
of information body of knowledge that is
included in 128 questions so yes there
is a lot of history in there US History
not New Hampshire history specifically
okay that was my concern that
I Is it wise that we well I won't I
won't start that way a sucess digital
assessment of the parentheses history
and government up top it talks about New
Hampshire and I've looked at it and I
haven't seen a whole lot of New
Hampshire history yes there's a lot of
continuity between our Constitution and
the Constitution of the United
States uh it's funny to mention that Mr
chairman I happen to be on a Civics
commission that has been tasked with uh
uh addressing that very uh situation of
developing a uh you know some Civics
infrastructure in in a textbook for uh
New Hampshire so that that uh I I assure
you is in the works uh with this
commission I sit on that commission too
I knew that and we have a meeting on
Wednesday the 7th
yes you're meeting on Wednesday
yeah yes represent myy thank you did I
hear
incorrectly that there was a new name
for this
test uh the question was is is there a
new name for this test uh not that I'm
aware of the the uh assessment is the U
the 128 question 2020 version of the
United States um it's in
the um I I only rise that because as
long as you're dealing with the bill if
there is a new name for it we should
probably put that in this particular
bill but I I I heard that yeah I heard
that from a teacher I think that said
well we don't have to do that now
because because they're not doing that
test anymore they've got a new test now
it's not in the not in the law sure that
type of confusion is is a concern that's
why in statute we specifically said this
is the 128 version 20 128 question 2020
version since 2020 they've gone back to
the 100 question version uh so that's
part perhaps why there's some some
confusion because uh they they went from
100 was 100 questions it went up to 128
and nowc back to 100 so we specifically
wanted the more rigorous there's more
knowledge in the 128 question version to
study so that specifically is in statute
is the assessment that the schools are
expected to uh uh administer further
questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
thank you Mr
this Dr Green okay just hoping you
step we'll need a pink card when you
yes if I
may my my question is a simple one uh
representative Moffett said that the the
new assessment system uh automatically
provides Provisions for persons with
disabilities Etc uh can you clarify that
a little bit since we've now eliminated
that one line 14- 19 from the proposed
legislation yeah so specifically in the
statute it had said schools are required
to provide accommodations and may modify
the Naturalization Examination for a
child with a disability and that was in
there previously because the schools
themselves were creating the test and so
not knowing what format that test might
be in the only person that would be able
to modify the test would have been the
school district in accordance with
students I AP under the Statewide
assessment system we have a a whole host
of accommodations that are built into
the system that are matched to students
IPS so schools now would no longer be
required to modify the test they just
need to make sure that the
accommodations are in the students IEP
so when the student goes in to take the
test those accommodations now will be
automatically applied um and that's
because the test itself would be
standardized within the state assessment
system if I may yes what kind of
accommodations are we talking about uh
so there could be a variety of
accommodations um some things are as
simple as allowing a student extra time
if you have a time test uh if you have a
student that has a particular uh Vision
impairment there are ways for the system
to create larger font uh to create more
contrasted font by changing the colors
of the text or the background of the
screen uh we have text to speeech
accommodations which are software
programs that will read text out loud to
students um so it really depends on the
particular disabilities are identified
in the students's
IEP further questions yes represent
cordelli uh thank you Dr Green um uh I I
think I um was in correct um previously
when I said it eliminates the um local
assessment requirement
um but I I'm was a little confused about
the uh getting rid of the um local
accommodations because um it seems like
on lines um two three and four and then
again in 10 there is a local assessment
options so if and on lines 10 it seems
that a local assessment and the US
citizenship test are required so
wouldn't the district be able to do
accommodations on the local assessment
that they develop yeah so special
education um is both a state requirement
and a federal requirement so schools
required under federal law to provide
the accommodations identified in student
IEP so if we didn't call it out at all
within this statute a school would still
be required to follow that child's IEP
um we had just removed it from that
sentence because it had referred
specifically to the Naturalization exam
um but it would regardless of whether
we're talking about the USCIS test or
the locally sanctioned competency
assessment uh school would be required
to provide students with
accommodations go ahead um thank you
just to follow up to representative
Myer's question do you know anything
about a new name for that test no I
believe that that's probably in
reference to the newer version of the
USCIS test um the 2020 version was the
128 question it's now reverted back to
uh a previous version that's now 100
questions um and actually if I could
just uh respond maybe a little bit to a
question that uh chairman lad had asked
earlier regarding the New Hampshire
history I think one of the reasons that
both the uh local competency assessment
and the Naturalization exam we in the
statute is that local competency
assessment is where you find much of the
New Hampshire based history um because
it isn't reflected in the USCIS test
which is more focused on United States
government and
structure yeah and I have one other
question that's not linked to that but
um is there a specific time that with
Statewide assessments we do that in
Spring um can this be given to a high
school student anywhere along their
pathway or is it Min if it's going
digital now are you going to request
that it be done at a certain time so
there are two things that we've looked
at because currently we only use the
Statewide assessment at the high school
level for juniors um so right now we
don't have freshman sophomore and
seniors that are routinely rostered into
our system we do have information on
seniors because they would have taken
the state test the previous year when
they were Juniors um so in building this
digitized version of the assessment
we've asked for two specific
specifications that would be that the
rostering system is uh encompassing of
all high school grades so all students 9
through 12 would have access to the test
um and then the test window itself would
be open um probably if not the full
school year but even a little bit into
the summer particularly given that this
is a graduation requirement you may have
students that are completing some of
their graduation requirements as they
going into summer and may even need a
little bit of time at the beginning of
Summer to fulfill some of their
requirements um and we know there are
districts that routinely have summer
graduations um for students that maybe
have a half a credit that they're still
completing or you know they're missing a
credit on their transcript or if there's
something uh like this where the test
itself is a graduation requirement and
they haven't taken it yet and who in
supervises the administration of this
test so that Johnny Smith doesn't have
David Hall do the test for him so with
the state assessment usually it's
coordinated with school counselors and
often times the math and the ELA
teachers of the high school uh because
current state assessment is uh focus on
math Ela uh and then
science excuse me um so likely would be
uh similar Personnel uh people that are
involved with social studies programs at
the high school uh in coordination with
uh building principal and school
counselors thank you further
questions thank you very much are there
any other pink cards on the senator do
you have anything to
say no
good anything else
thank you very much we will close this
day check mark
some oh yeah yeah
card
these I don't know see I I think that on